yeah man i was wearing a uh like a
stylish
coat and because i thought today was
gonna be a little cooler yeah not cooler
not cooler so i had to shoot something
with kenny floyd before this then i was
like oh i'm
sweating my ass off so i went to my car
i'm like what i have in there i had this
old school because it still says devil
it says tampa bay devil race and it's
autographed by
i have i have no clue it says like keep
your head up
and then it's autographed by another
grown man is there a number on the back
or anything
no i don't know what's going on i have
no idea where this came from
but it says keep your head up like
you're a teenager yeah like some kid
first of all it's authentic because it
has like the cause it says authentic and
it has like the
the velcro for the players you know but
devil raise means
many years ago because the the the
league made him change from devil rays
to raise
i don't know what year that was i don't
know if they're still a team yeah their
team
the razor team they've been so bad good
this year
are they good they're good this year
because it's a shortened season and they
have great pitching
but they have it's a terror it's a tough
i threw out the first they can't be
called devil rich they're not called
devil rage they're called the rays now i
threw at the first pitch in that stadium
oh really
yeah um and uh
it was funny i've thrown the first
picture a couple places
in boston they were they said to me they
said do you want to
what size jersey do you wear so we can
have you in a jersey when you walk out
to the
red sox game yeah and a green monster
dude they said what kind of jerry what
size jersey do you need and i said
whatever size is going to cover up my
boner
because i'm going to be [ __ ] super
happy dude the red sox
that's my name i did my okay this was
the most embarrassing part
as a person as a as a as a young boy
growing up massachusetts
you know i'm sure so you have teams but
wherever you are you still have
a team even if your city has three teams
you're either a football guy
you're a nuggets guy or broncos guy you
know what i mean you pick yours i'm
broncos nuggets
so for me but the red sox above
everything else above the patriots above
the southeast sure
so when i when they said you can throw
out the first pitch i was like oh
big deal man i was i
practiced i wore i practiced i can't
stand the people that don't practice
and [ __ ] up like 50 cent yeah come on
man
if you know you can't throw you're just
i'll cheat do a pitch and it's just
a nightmare he's 150 i'm going to give
him a break yeah
you know but if you're if you're 50 cent
and you know you throw like
you know you throw righty like somebody
throwing lefty who doesn't throw
lefty you know what i mean make a joke
out of it but don't go out there like
you got it so bad
so i go out there and as i'm walking out
so this is a
lifelong dream dude i'm walking out
my dad's there it's his birthday and
you're all in red sox
jersey my son is there my wife is there
my mom is there they're all on the field
watching they're on the field this is
like a
huge moment and as i'm walking out
onto the field i hear uh and now ladies
and gentlemen throw out the first pitch
lifelong red sox fan a native
of massachusetts when i listed my
credits and i'll list
your name up yeah and he goes please
welcome john wolfe and i was like oh
[ __ ] so dishonest
oh my god i'd rather not do it i looked
over
jacob i looked over at jacob and jacob
gave me a [ __ ]
thumbs down he just looked at me my dad
was laughing
my brother's name is john and he he lo
he was like man
even when i'm not there i still own you
that's hilarious
it was how did the pitch i mean he
played baseball so you're good right
yeah
i i i'm all right i got booed at the
first pitch in oakland
you pitched for a local days i go i
throw the first pitch in oakland
dude i i would love to throw a pitch for
the colorado rockies
you 100 good uh you'd be surprised
because last year
i know my team reached out to him that i
came because it's when i was doing
comedy works yeah like hey bren you know
denver boy born and raised rocky's fan
and they said ah usually with the first
pitch it's usually tied to
our donors so unless he wants to donate
money he's like
what no rockies yeah who's donating to
the
here we go here's the raise first [ __ ]
right here
oh you're familiar with my my double
raise yeah
no so my buddy who caught is a guy named
derek shelton
you get a pick who catches he's the real
deal derek is now the
co the manager for the uh pirates
but he's a buddy of mine oh yeah yeah
i'm gonna play baseball so that's legit
come on man we we got it vouchers might
have been the worst he was
he thought the ball had covered he was
he was teasing me he was like man
nobody's ever thrown out of first pitch
in skinny jeans before i'm like watch
watch me but look how many people are in
the stands not a ton
and no one it doesn't really matter who
it is no one gets crunk for the guy
throwing the first pitch ever i've seen
big star
especially at dodger stadium yeah though
it'd be like some big ass like we got
john legend
no one gives a fly [ __ ] in l.a it's even
worse
the only time uh anyone's ever given a
[ __ ]
in my that i remember is when i got
booed
i got boone in oakland dude because the
guy who threw out the first pitch before
me
they said hey oh that was terrible i'm
not listening to anything
i mean i said look look the truth you
throw baseball like that as an american
i can't listen to you on anything it's
not it's not great but i'm giving him
i mean he's he's three days older than
baseball so
you know what i mean so baseball started
1912
don't do it dude but let me ask you
something is it more embarrassing for
him
or say 50 cent or carl lewis who are
young
all all the above all the other loose
was terrible
50 cent probably the worst i think so
he's kind of a [ __ ] talker
i was i was expecting that more out of
50
because he he walked out with a little
bit of confidence you know
i'm trying to think he was throwing the
best i mean your pitch was legit but
there's been
some there's been some dynamite some
celebrities with some [ __ ] ropes on
them
you know what might be the best yeah
george w bush you ever seen the ropey
throughout the texans game
granted he owns them he threw a good one
also
on uh the first pitch 50 is the worst
what the [ __ ] worse than fouchy but way
worse dude you know who you know who
threw a
[ __ ] bullet was a what was his name
it was a a quarterback i forgive her i
forget i forget whoever
yeah sure who threw a missile
how where would you rate yourself as far
as like because baseball skills are
different than
uh baseball skills are different than
like other
sports do you know what i mean like you
can be a great
baseball player and not be a
particularly good
yeah oh well russell wilson got drafted
by the new york yankees
yeah first round yeah he was look at
that look at that
first and it had a little
come on dude yeah you can't
but but but to me the single hardest
thing to do in any sport
is hit a baseball hit a baseball yeah do
you agree with the game of losses
because you you you're trying to just
it's the hardest thing
but that's the game like it's a game of
failure right yeah the hardest job in
professional sports is starting
quarterback in the nfl
without a doubt this the worst game you
have to you have to think about
quarterback start thinking now think how
many are
good yeah well you it's exhausting you
have to
you have to you have to have so many
different skills
because at the end of the day you can
also be a great quarterback but if
you're not a great
leader i'm assuming when you walk into
that huddle you got no respect but
yeah as a quarterback for most that you
have to be really smart
you're basically another coach you're an
extension of coach you gotta be
those guys are so [ __ ] smart like tom
brady's
by no means the best athlete he's the
smartest yeah he
he knows what he he studies so much he
knows what you're going to
do russell wilson smartest guy did you
watch
the [ __ ] clippers i know you did my
nuggets you talking about the nug nuts
yeah yeah
dude can we can we order my [ __ ]
jersey it should be here tomorrow
i was gonna wear it today tell me
honestly going into the game last night
what were you thinking me and my brother
thought they were gonna win well after
they beat them last game
because they've been down 16. they've
been down 19 and we're like dude if
you're down that much and
you're still winning they got their
number and when jokic and murray are on
and then porter barely did anything last
night dude they beat the [ __ ] out here's
my big question
we're gonna be delicious here's my big
question like
maybe because we match up better with
the lakers honestly
like if anybody was gonna shut down
murray
that perimeter defense from the clippers
should have been
right between george or or beverly or
kawhi somebody well you got beverly and
you got lou williams coming off the
bench both six men of the year
like they were so stacked so what's to
like me and my brother taught me this
last night is it a is it a matter of
the nuggets just being better or did the
clippers just
lose that series can i because because
technically and clay travis
vouchs for this the clippers are the
best team in the nba hands down
top to the bottom talents coach-wise by
far
yeah by far yeah they're the best team
they should
have won the championship yeah so i
think it's about them kind of dropping
the ball
the you know kawaii and uh george just
got i've never seen
you know kwai went six for 22. dude they
went offer in the fourth combined they
you know i think doc rivers has lost
three three three so i think he's been
up in
three to six coach so if you stick
around long enough [ __ ] happens okay
but i think you think it's him i i think
it's on the players
okay because you can't because what can
doc
do to make kawhi and george hot like
when they go
out about the best play in the league
goes six for 22. it's like
if you're doc there's no doubt about did
you see
boston [ __ ] miami dude butler let me
ask you this one question before we get
on to that because you know i'm a boston
fan me too
but don't you think after the third time
that you're
and by the way it's not like this dude
outside of boston hasn't had talent he
had chris paul blake griffin deandre
jordan
all in their prime and matt barnes and
mapper
all in their prime so like i know
players love doc and dude he brought
boss in a championship
but at some point in time we have to
start wondering why he's not doing more
with this crazy amount of talent oh
they're happy
they're they're most stacked in the nba
this one was crazy
to me they should have won it uh do you
think though and i know you
you think denver matches up better with
the lakers but don't you think
anthony davis handles jokic well
anthony djokovic joking no djokovic is a
tennis player joking jokic
joking djokovic is the tennis player i
think i think they're similar
i think one is jay oh we just call him
the joker okay
that's his nickname they call him the
joker but eight so ads actually a power
forward and jokage
is a uh center so they won't cover each
other and if ad were to cover jokage
jokage will just light him up with three
because a.d can't cover on the on the
perimeter no
or maybe it doesn't matter he's gonna be
draining [ __ ] threes crazy boys
they match up well with them who knows
if they win it all it's just nuts we're
in the
finals like dude as a kid i remember
when the nuggets went yeah i think it
was 1993 maybe the
the sonics yeah with my tumbo yeah
holding that ball that's one of the most
like yeah shots of any basketball series
by the way loki my favorite i'm curious
what you said about this my favorite
player
not in a boston uniform ever
maybe in any sport is gary payton oh
interesting
i love the glove i [ __ ] love what a
team i loved the type of game
he had because he would lock you down i
love shows oh
my god and i was in seattle and i
watched
peyton and are you there during the do
you ever go to sean kemp's bar
no but sean kemp used to have sex with
my ex
i didn't know that they have kids no he
has like he has like 19 kids yeah
sean kemp fox it was something she told
me like six months into the relationship
i'm like you should have opened with
that you should've you should have led
with i used to [ __ ] sean cannon kemp was
slanging your girl your old girl yeah
yeah yeah my old my um
shawn kemp dude it's the least you can
do i enjoy his games
i enjoy did you enjoy his game
give your girl up for our entertainment
dude it's the least you can do but
john kemp the dunk master dude who's
who's outside of your teams who's your
favorite player
um a guy you wrote for butler
i as a team i i think boston could win
it i hope they do right i mean my son
boston for god's sakes
that's how much i love the city of
boston so i i root for the celtics
i think is it the best team going uh so
i root for butler i
root for uh russell westbrook um
i like westbrook too man same reason
he's like he's got that cut like the
killers
me too uh my favorite player is kevin
durant
no is he the slim reaper favorite player
i mean i love his game i just i mean and
who the [ __ ] am i to criticize anybody
how they handle their own business off
but the whole social media thing with
him
it's just the petty stuff i don't care i
wish he didn't pay attention me too me
too
it bums me out when i find out people
who i admire pay attention that stuff it
gets to them or they have depression
from it yeah i
get it because social media is a
[ __ ]
you have 400 million dollars in the bank
yeah right what are you doing dude i'm
like why even pay someone to run that
for you why are you paying attention
my thing is go in the gym and shoot
[ __ ] free throws if
there's no way in the world somebody who
i didn't know
existed can bother me with anything they
say
do you know what i mean like i didn't
know you existed bro yeah
so this doesn't bother what you're
saying you're a nameless faceless
doesn't bother me and i
i'm with you i wish it didn't bother him
i think i think
athletes comics anybody in the spotlight
there needs to be some sort
of uh liaison or specialist to help them
navigate through that social media world
not to give it so much
attention i think there should be some
sort of service where people learn to
deal with it better
it's a real problem man for a lot of
people do you know what i try to do man
is i take an hour one hour a day
and i because i like to respond to
people
um because i uh i like to
it's just who i am like i like the
interaction
i love i really like it i like it after
shows i don't like it on
uh social media i like it after show
yeah i like the fan engagement eye to
eye
you do i do know i have heard from a lot
of people
who have been to your shows and been
like his meet and greets are
long because you'll talk to people oh
yeah me too chatty cathy me too dude
yeah especially
especially if it's good questions or a
good convo yeah like a lot of people
give me
advice on the city uh where to eat
bike rides bikes they have like it's fun
dude
cars shoes like you'll notice my crowd
has the the best shoes that far i can't
decide on it and then they'll make fun
of me
like if i don't wear like now i always
bring out my hitters because
i'm just in like some basic nikes
they'll come up like dude what the [ __ ]
all right dude it's rainy out here man i
don't know
so ever since then i'll never forget
some guy goes dude what the [ __ ] man
we waited three months and these are the
shoes you wore i'm like
oh yeah i'm coming for the shoe i'm the
shoe guy i'm the shoe guy yeah my bad
my bad what was the fir the first pair
of
shoes you bought where you were like
these are
[ __ ] oh jordan fives the laser reds
yeah you still have them no i [ __ ]
wish
i couldn't wear them but yeah i was that
was when i was a kid
yeah i did do like now now it's now it's
a little different like i posted this uh
instagram post what are those jordan 5's
look like is that what
uh they would be just the
uh one over chin those
me and my brother both got those
my favorite shoe of all time the jordan
ones are my favorite shoe of all time
uh but those are the most sentimental
shoe that is i bought them for my
brother when they came out i bought them
for my brother
how much were they doing back then i
don't know we were kids that
had to spend a hundred bucks i guess for
kid shoes yeah dude i still for me
i still remember those white red and
black
old school for me they're the first
jordans i remember seeing
and to me those are still my all-time
favorite they might be the ones i don't
know but they
probably the ones the white the white
red and black yeah the ones
yeah i had never i remember when he
first started wearing those shoes they
were so
yeah those are them i can't believe play
basketball on those you ever like those
are not
they're not those right there they're
not fun to
they're like there's no support in them
no there's but they're much going on
so good but even like the like these the
like dunks or the hotness right now
dunks are the hype beasts
what people don't dunks are
skateboarding shoes yeah these are stiff
as [ __ ]
like if i if i walk far in like let's
say i'm in new york i can't wear dunks
my feet will because i'm 37 my feet will
be destroyed by time you get back to the
hotel
yeah you're also 37 you're wearing furry
orange shoes so
yeah but it doesn't matter fur no fur
python leather
these are made for [ __ ] skateboarding
and they're stiff as [ __ ]
that's why dude the reason i stick with
puma they're so comfy is they're so
comfortable
and i'm at the old i told you what
happened to me old man this weekend and
i'm at an old man
stage in my life but pumas are dope man
like you wear those with jeans or
anything yeah yeah
absolutely are you have you ever thought
about
designing a shoe i did one for this
brand new york brand called
greats i did one uh fire and kid collab
with them
yeah and uh yeah that was great well how
did i 100
was that 100 your you get to design them
yep and how did you go about like did
you
look at a lot of well they they have a
base that you have to start from
oh they're oh yeah they're right here so
so great they're leather shoes so i
couldn't get too crazy
because i like crazy shoes but when
you're appealing to the mask you can't
do crazy
so these are i like them man you know
what i also like
see i like the thick on the bottom yeah
i know a lot of
people don't know great they're they're
amazing they're crushed they're big time
now
they want to return my call shout out to
ryan
but this i mean these these sold out in
minutes yeah those are super dope yeah
are are you uh are you being extra
careful
with your family and the air quality
and all that [ __ ] i went on a run
yesterday because i dropped my son off
from school i had some down time so i
was like i'll i'll run like my old run
i'll go
from venice pier to santa monica pier
and i was running talking my dad on the
phone
so i wasn't paying attention hey i
haven't ran in a while i'm so [ __ ]
sore it's not
even funny but b i felt like [ __ ] dude
yeah and
you see they said the air quality is the
worst in the world you're telling me our
air quality is worse than
[ __ ] beijing china right now we're
worse than india
right now la's worse than india i didn't
i would be smart i'm like man my nose
was stuffy
i just my chest is heavy i've just kind
of been like my head's like in the
clouds
and it's it's just in inhaling this
horrible [ __ ]
my i was telling you i went on a bike
ride and i
wiped my face just with like a cloth
and it was black jesus because all the
soot had stuck to the sweat and i was
like that's what i'm breathing
in and then my son who's got a little
bit of
jacob's got a little bit of asthma yeah
but i can tell when
when [ __ ] is hitting his lungs he was
outside for maybe an hour
he came back in not only was he was like
oh i feel terrible but he had these deep
black circles jesus yeah when the news
tells you that's unhealthy out there
should probably listen but they're so
full of [ __ ] again it's tough that it's
like
okay yeah right well they're right dude
i wear my mask now more
outside yeah because of the air because
that's the kind of [ __ ] that sticks
in your lawn yeah that's not good yeah
not get power through it i'll be fine
yeah
but um well i meant that dude with you
growing up with with your kids when
they're little have you ever had any
close calls like this
last night so boston goes to bed at uh
six o'clock like we put give him a bath
every night we have routine
it's six o'clock on the dot take him up
takes a bath drinks his milk
goes to bed right turn that off yeah go
ahead
sorry about that all right so the kids
are on a
strict routine we don't they take their
nap at this
certain time but especially boston as a
newborn i think it was a better certain
time to eat at the same time
there's strict routine my girl's anal
about it strict routine
so six o'clock he goes up mean tigers
stay down we usually watch rick and
morty and eat a snack or whatever before
he goes to bed at seven might take him
up for
a shower so me and uh tiger down there
it's like 6
15 and we're watching rick and morty
it's a little loud and i hear my girl
going bran
brad screaming oh no then i hear this
thud i'm like what the [ __ ]
so i put the team on me and she goes i
can hear in her voice bran it's panic
and i [ __ ] i go tigers stay here and i
sprint upstairs of course tiger follows
me but i sprint upstairs
boston is purple can't breathe [ __ ] i'm
talking
like an eggplant purple yeah and he
drank his milk
fast and then it came up and he like
burped or swallowed something got stuck
like the powder or something and it came
through his nose
and he couldn't breathe so you know i
just and you know what help me
this is crazy to say this you know what
what my mind went to remember that video
of that
cop with the baby doing it like this
that i just went all that clapped it so
i took boston and started hitting him
like literally that's hard like this
nothing
nothing nothing where were you on the
back on the back and i told my girl i'm
putting them down i go call call
9-1-9-1-1
but in my head i'm like these guys you
know it's just the
area you know la such a big county yeah
by the time they get here
i don't get this he's he's dead he's a
goner yeah
keep doing it finally he's crying like a
[ __ ] but dude
yeah and i took cpr when i was i'm nasm
certified when i was like lost after i
got cut from the nfl i didn't know i was
gonna do so i got certified uh
nasa which is national academy for
sports medicine
to get the certification you have to
take a cpr class
and so they teach you kids and stuff
like that so i remember a little bit of
that but that's more mouth-to-mouth not
if the kid's choking so now you know i i
told my girl i'm like you
you know laurie who's our caretaker your
mom
anybody who watches kids we need to have
it well i'm gonna have somebody come to
the crib i don't know if there's a
service out there
dm me or email find the kids shop at
gmail.com
there's a service that can come and show
them cpr and how to get do that for
babies dude
we were i didn't i didn't
i didn't sleep last night i slept in his
room on the floor for probably the first
three hours
and it was just like just to make sure
he was good
so scary because it's like dude and you
and
i tiger was crying because tiger saw
chills just tiger saw how like
panicked i was and like sprinted up
there and he came late
so he's crying because he's seen his
brother purple which i didn't want him
to see yeah
and then he's like why is he purple then
i'm you know he saw the frantic in his
mom in my eyes
so then tiger felt that vibe so tiger's
crying
boston's crying and the tigers hugging
his brother kissing on him
after he was breathing tiger was so
scared buddy
yeah the the it was it [ __ ]
it those kind of things also show you
how
quickly it can how fragile life is yeah
man how quickly it can turn
the kids choking was always
one of my biggest [ __ ] fears it
uh only happened one time i asked my
girl like did he just
did you not give him a break between the
mouth did you burp him she goes i did
everything i do every night
yeah and i i was sitting with him and
then he was like
and then you could tell he was like and
then it went through his nose ain't
gonna breathe and
he got something got stuck in there yeah
it's
it is a so scary dude frightening
like let me ask you something did when
everyone went to sleep did you cry for a
little while just
oh i i cried right soon he started
breathing i was crying i would have just
because there's so it makes you realize
in that moment holy
[ __ ] like like this this is how fragile
things are yeah
three like like my whole honestly dude
that's a
three minutes that's the difference
between you being here and just being
able to tell a story in three [ __ ]
minutes oh my life is over dude yeah
like any of my kids go with like
no no you're not seeing brendan doing it
no it's
so crazy and but that's that kind of
stuff
also can make you
hyper parent do you know what i mean
like helicopter
any cough anything you're like you're
okay everything and it's gonna wait too
hard
it's so hard i couldn't wait for him to
get up just to see him and then what
you know he's such a kid and i'm sure it
was or such a baby infant
i'm sure it was traumatic for him but
once i picked him up and i just carried
him outside just to calm him down
and then he's just so happy and playful
yeah and i told tyler i'm like look come
he's fine dude he's fine
he's grabbing tiger's face by the way
that's really important to me anyways
again i'm not a parent
expert but to me it's important for you
not to constantly be scared about it
because
when you're scared they're scared the
kids can sense yes so if you're if you
if that
if that time if that moment if that
freak accident changes you and your wife
into
worried people when you're a worried
parent a kid the kids are worried
parents and what's interesting you know
tiger's
four and a half so my girl don't want to
scare him she would you know she didn't
know but tiger goes
what's purple my girl goes oh i dropped
something on the ground that something
on the ground's purple and yeah
no it's not i'm like you i'm telling you
he's too smart from this
he's like we gotta tell him what
happened like boston was purple because
he couldn't breathe when he can't
breathe you turn blue and blue
and he's like oh i got it papa too so
what happens if you can't breathe
it's like then you die you think boston
was gonna die like if you didn't breathe
yeah dude
that's that's why that's why your dad
was so scared that's why your dad ran up
there and did that and that's why you
said and that's why you better go to bed
on time
yeah yeah he starts saying [ __ ] like
that i remember
i wish man when your kids have any
health problems i don't mean they're
right yeah
jacob growing up did he yeah jake
because boss or
tiger had uh benign epileptic seizures
but we don't know what it was
so when he was getting like i've never
he's crying he's
two they have his whole head covered
bandaged with all these
wires hanging off of him and they're
doing all these scans dude
dude my girl i'm like man if it's
something like a tumor or something he
doesn't make this do us
no there's no coming back well for me
it's i'm done yeah there's no
i don't want to be here no there's no
coming back and you know i'm not
positive dude i don't struggle with
there's no coming back from that when i
when i'm out yeah i don't want to be
here i don't know how people do it i
don't either for me the biggest one
when jacob was i probably four and a
half five
uh we went i flew cross country with
jacob and i was just dating
beth at the time so he was probably four
and a half maybe five yeah and
uh we were going into connecticut for
my friend's wedding and jacob was
staying
at my parents in upstate new york and my
mom called and she said um
he can't breathe and i said what and she
said he
he i go he's choking she's like no he's
not able to catch a breath
we're standing outside in like 40 degree
weather it's the only place he can catch
him catch his breath
and i was like what do you mean like not
breathe and she's put the phone up to
his
like and i'm like how are you doing
buddy and he was like i just care
and i was like [ __ ] i'm hours away
there's like
that's the thing like for me i was i'm
now
helpless you and i have talked about
this before like one of the hardest
things for me
when my son deployed and he was in
afghanistan was you are completely
helpless did you try to talk him out of
that going in the army
yeah no not when he gave me the reason
what was his reason you know he called
me do you say dad do you like your
freedom
yeah like yeah i do but i don't
i'm gonna send an eagle to your house
right now navy seal
no he said to me he was in college and
he was 10 days in and he goes i'm not
gonna make it i go
are you already failing they haven't
even given you a test yet yeah and he
was like i'm not prepared for this i
don't he's
basically he said i don't have enough
discipline
to be here this isn't for me this is he
basically said i don't have enough
discipline to be here
and he said i want to go and he had been
living with his mom for a little while
so
he was spent high school with his mom
and so
i said what do you mean he's like i just
don't have enough discipline to make
this work
and i said okay and go what do you want
to do he said i think i'm going to join
the army
and i said all right something and he
said i just need
structure yeah i need structure i need
structure really bad you say well
there's a chance you could be deployed
for war well there was no doubt when he
was going
to to me what that means right yeah to
me what's scary is like
you go to war it's not like world war ii
or world war
world war one it's like now we're going
towards it's very political buddy
you know it's like you're yet you're
kind of fighting for our freedom
depending
where you're being stationed stuff like
that but also a lot of it's political
which is tough for me but for me it was
more like
at least you know the guys who came home
from vietnam were not welcome
when he came back he said he was
welcomed by everybody with open arms so
like
so so that i wasn't worried did he was
he like in the
[ __ ] yeah they call it yeah yeah did i i
told you that story about that video he
wanted to show at my
at the welcome home party right yeah so
like but my biggest thing can you talk
about it or cf ptsd
uh he's got he's he's got some issues
you know he's he's not as bad as some
guys and and but he's got his own
he's got some physical issues and he's
got something he's done is he done
he is done i think he's getting med
boarded out he's just got some physical
what's he gonna do what does he know
what he wants to do he's gonna move to
nashville
with me love it and because you know we
haven't
hang out for a long time yeah how old is
he he's 27.
he's young yeah but does he know what he
does he have any idea what he wants to
do
no man he you know what he said yeah he
was like man i
just i just want to hang for a little
while and and and see what i like
because i don't even know what i like
but i'm psyched 100 but that's what they
like whether it's whether it's soldiers
and you know who get deployed they get
done with their service
or it's professional whatever athletes
they are or
entertainers like when you're done there
or college students
when you're done there's that weird law
period where you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're gonna do and try to figure
out
i think everyone goes through that yeah
i know some people you know it's so bad
for soldiers or
uh what you know what's a ufc fighter
gonna do i'm like the same thing
this graduating college class is gonna
have to [ __ ] figure out dude
like you get done you're kind of like
all right i majored in communications
yeah i'm not gonna get a job right away
yeah i went to
i went to loyola it's like no one gives
a [ __ ] nobody gives them you're going to
have to network and figure out
something you're going to do now but
then for fighters it's scary too it's
like hold up i've been doing this for
the last
seven years i'm known as a fighter and
i'm i'm not doing this i gotta figure
out it's like yeah
everyone has that period it's scariest
didn't you and i think fighters
uh athletes in general anybody that's in
a business
where there's an adrenaline rush i think
when you leave that business
you miss you know my son will tell you
he
when he came back being deployed chasing
the dragon he wanted to go back and
chase the dragon
and did you feel like was there that it
did
does comedy feel that a little bit for
you i was just talking about my
therapist yesterday about it it's like
you know through comedy i get that same
dopamine that same
yeah satisfaction that i did from
fighting without being scared to get
kicked in the face
that which is a huge difference do you
do you like as far as
homework goes for for fighting
and for comedy do you know what i mean
are there any similarities at all in
preparation
obviously not like like the actual
physicality of it but like
how you prepare for a fight how you get
into it mentally is there any
similarities at all
i think maybe the work ethic from being
like disciplined and fighting and
carrying that
over to comedy and podcasting has helped
me the most
but you people always i hate when people
say oh he has a
fighter's work ethic no not all fighters
are like this i'd have this work ethic
if i work for ups
like you know my dad isn't a
professional athlete and he has a crazy
work ethic like it's a
that's a that's a character trait yeah
it's not a professional athlete trait
i hate when people say oh is an
athlete's work ethic listen some of the
laziest people i know on this [ __ ]
earth are professional athletes come on
but talented as [ __ ] they're just
talented but they're lazy as [ __ ]
some of the comics we know lazy as [ __ ]
dude how do you not have
you don't have a new ten minutes what
have you been doing you've been doing
the same
20-minute set for how many years yeah
but again that's not a that's not a
that's a work ethic
whether you're talented comedian which
most these guys are or you're talented
fighter or talented football player
just because you're a professional
athlete i cannot stand when people go
oh the only reason he's successful
because he is a work ethic a fighter's
work ethic
no it's just a work ethic period no
matter what i'm doing
i i couldn't agree with you more it
drives me it's one of my pet peeves i
hate when people say that but like
when i see people doing
the same at this comedy store the comedy
store not on the road where you people
are paying to hear your a material
when i see somebody same set yeah for
like eight but they've been doing for
almost longer than that but you know it
crushes but i'm like
because you guys haven't seen it before
yeah but yeah i'm gonna have to follow
him i know i'm gonna eat dicks
he's been doing this for four years
though and by the way
the truth of the matter is is that the
way you get better
is to fail take care you gotta shoot
your
[ __ ] shot you're gonna go four for
twenty like why did do you know what
dude sometimes you're gonna go four for
22 or six for 22.
but then sometimes you shouldn't go 10
for 10 100 and you learn
do you know what i did for three
separate years so i used to be
a heavy pacer like almost chris rocky
growing back
yeah it almost chris rock and then i was
like okay
i just think i'm moving too much because
i just would see people's heads
so this is what i did for three years in
a row so for the first year i stood
behind the mic
never took it out of the uh mic stand
just never sat down stood there the next
full tour
i sat down the whole time like marc
maron the whole time
power power move and then i stood up
because i re i found out what parts of
my jokes
worked better in stillness when you're
moving and which parts needed movement
and it made every story so much better
because
some of the parts of the jokes needed me
to be still
yes and some needed energy it's more
powerful when
it makes it better when you move because
it counts it's like swearing i was doing
the same thing and chris delia told me
he watched my sega's dude
that was good he was do you notice
though you're moving a ton
yeah because i move a ton but i move
when it matters it goes in
like like me you're a big dude yeah so
when you're moving non-stop it's almost
a distraction
he's like so move when it counts move
when you want them to pay attention
it really helps yeah and your size i
told joe diaz that early on
because he used to pace like crazy in
his three-piece suit
and i was like dude you're scaring the
[ __ ] out of people i think it's a
distraction too
yeah you know yeah that helped me
tremendously have you
uh i gotta be honest i'm a little
hungover i've been hungover and i don't
know how many
from what yellowstone dude i saw that
picture of you with your hat and your
whiskey
i'm like look with my if i don't see a
lasso in that next picture i don't know
what i'm gonna do
i'll see what i can i get a lasso
dude i you know we watch yellowstone and
i drink whiskey
and then i and then i woke up this
morning because ever you know we're
we're
in the middle of season two and it's
dude it's
so [ __ ] good it's the best show i've
ever seen
okay i'm so into it i'm gonna i'm
drinking this whiskey because they drink
whiskey on there i'm in my cowboy hat
and we're season two and um and and then
like the i'm like we can only my rule is
we can only watch two episodes a night
otherwise we're gonna blow through this
to have nothing to [ __ ] do because
right nothing out so we can only watch
two at night
and i find myself when we first started
watching i just have
maybe you know just one whiskey now i'm
up to two to three
and i'm so into it i don't even notice i
have nicotine in just like
[ __ ] a dutton like i'm on the ranch i
have nicotine in
i have my hat on and and we got done
with it and i was like
oh i'm a little but i'm pretty drunk
i go to bed you know we go to bed at 9
30 10.
you go to bed at 9 30 sometimes nine
yeah
i can't get to sleep i'm an early bird
so then my son always wakes him up
5 30 or 6 6 if i'm lucky this morning 5
30 and i i wake up like bubba well give
me a second he goes come on he always
grabs my hand goes
come on papa let's go downstairs let's
go downstairs i'm like give give dad a
second here i'm like
i want to be like that's hungover yeah
5 30. i got a belly oh i got to stop
doing this is this the first time you've
been hungover for new kids
yeah but they don't know dude i coached
a baseball game
still a little high on ecstasy my son we
were down at poinsettia park
and uh i coached all my there was this
one team one year
that we went to sign them up and they
were like yeah sign ups unless you want
to coach
your kid can't be on a team and i was
like why and i was like i said
baseball yeah i go yeah i'll coach and
they said cool here are the leftover
kids that didn't get drafted
so that was the team we had yeah we had
four bad news bears
here's the little giant dude we had four
russian kids
three didn't russians russians i was
even i was in hollywood the only thing i
don't do well
besides make creative [ __ ] uh baseball
they definitely
go ahead name the best russian baseball
player i'll [ __ ] wait
i think he would might have been on our
team
dude we we co we so one day we show up
and uh it was late and this was back
when i was
single raising the three kids and so
i didn't get to go out very often so if
i was going out i was going
out you're like that single cougar mom
who goes out and it is
awesome it is a german [ __ ] it's on
like [ __ ]
yeah let's get this
yeah yeah get it mom
carton of milk and baked potato let's go
we're we're sitting in front of the
couch waiting it's happy hour it's
[ __ ] sliding
i'm re i'm like so my we were going out
and
there was some ecstasy that night and
they're like you know take some and i
was like yeah
10 o'clock game i should be able to be
are you a big xc guy
no i was for about six month period
the next morning so sad well that's why
i just kept taking it so sad so i was it
was like i took it
and then my brother was like hey man uh
you want another one i was like what
time is it
and he's like it's midnight i'm like
yeah i'll take another one he's like
what time's that game i go 10.
i said i should be fine so around 3am i
go man i either gotta take another one
or go to sleep he's like let's take
another one
good for him good for him because he was
my
we coached together yeah yo we showed up
you guys blitzed a little bit
i i kept my sunglasses on because you
know my eyes were still a little [ __ ]
up yeah
pupils the size of [ __ ] sauce i'll
tell you what though they coat the kids
up rubbing your thighs
they were like coach wolf was really
drinking a lot of orange juice this
morning i'm like
good head man [ __ ] dude yeah i told
everybody i was like everybody's doing a
great job today man well he's real
handsy with the kids y'all
just dude we had a kid on the team
this russian kid brandon okay so
he was a little lefty he had such
great natural skill as a pitcher like
when the first time he threw it i'm like
oh this kid is
legit this is our ice box but he was not
showing up to a lot of the practices so
i asked one of his russian buddies i'm
like where
where is he and he goes yeah no he goes
he teaches he helps his dad during the
day
work i go what is that dude he goes his
dad's a dentist
i go oh so i said can you give me the
address to the office
i'm going to go over there and see if i
can't talk him into letting me have i
think his name was alex alex come down
and pitch more he's really good
so he gives me the address and i'm
finding the address i drive
over it's an apartment building in
hollywood
and it's an apartment number and i walk
up and i go in and outside there's some
chairs in the
hallway people waiting in line and i go
is this the dentist none of them spoke
english and they knock on the door
and alex opens the door it's an
apartment
like an apartment they're doing some
side hustle with a dentist
chair in the living room oh weird so no
living room it was a dentist chair was
like no insurance being taken here
no insurance and not only that you know
what was right next to the living room
in the apartment in hollywood
the kitchen oh yeah so mom is cooking
food
while this dude has his mouth open on
the dentist chair tight hustle though
a 10 year old kid is the dental
assistant
maybe not your best move tough so i come
in and i'm like
hey and i'm looking around i'm like oh
my friend how old are you kid
10 i'm your goddamn good coach man 10
11. i walk away and i talk to the dad
i'm like can i get
i was he was like can you we talked
after the guy left and he was i was like
is it possible for alex to come
he's like i need help with the family
business jesus christ and i was like
what what can i do
to make sure he at least makes the games
and he was like
can you pay for his shift i'm like no i
mean you can't
i'm like but it says cam newton's dead
what i'm not trying to go to do
we're just trying to pitch at the
[ __ ] washington park yeah come on man
i'm just trying to get
you know but he finds the family
business dude he finally he would come
down
taking off his scrubs on the way to the
field but he was a baller
dude this little kid could whip it man
interesting
he could whip it we had the it was a
weird year dude we had
a the one of the other russian kids
thought he was white black
and called the kids on the other teams
he was a russia he used to call them my
n-word
when they got on for he played first
base for me wow and i shouldn't drop in
the n-bomb
to the other kids and i'd have to go hey
man you can't do that here this is not
and he was like no we're all the same
i'm like no no no but
how and how long did you coach your
kid's team i coached
jacob's team this was man the hardest
thing for me about my career
is that i coached jakey's and and all
the kids teams
i coached jacob's team up until he was
12 years old and then i started going on
the road
and i went from not missing a game ever
to missing every one that's where i
struggle because when tiger starts
playing i'm not going to miss a
[ __ ] game but they play on saturday
yeah so they're going to be like oh
brendan's in
in [ __ ] at in dallas he's doing
tuesday wednesday thursday shows
dude like that's what i'm that's just
what i'm gonna have to do or hopefully
by the time they're
in sports i'm a big enough name or i can
just do theater so yeah
just friday nights i'm flying back
saturday morning that's my plan i want
to get famous enough so i want when your
famous stuff where i'm just doing
two theater shows on a friday night
saying coaching my
little leagues doable and let me tell
you from somebody who
hit everything up until age 12 and
didn't hit anything after age 12.
we talked about this before like that in
our brains every show is super important
yes
i'm gonna tell you right now it's not
missing me i
hate my biggest regret and without a
doubt my biggest regret and i have
apologized to him
profusely is that i got in that
mindset of i need this gig i got to do
the next gig this is that money
i can't turn that money down i don't
know when that money is going to stop i
gotta do that money
and i wasn't there for his prom not
worth it
not worth it and i i've i've had more
yeah one go around dude one go around
there's one ride on the rock
and so you have to decide what the
really important things are
and i'm going to tell you something it's
a [ __ ] problem so important i talked
i talked to my girl and finally
trying for another for a third i want
four
you you want but she was like two she
was like i'm [ __ ] done i'm like dude
imagine one more imagine a little
brendan jr
you don't want them to outnumber you bro
you want to be able to play man-to-man
not zone
we're going to zone it are you going to
zone it we're going zone
the way i convinced my own like could be
a girl she wants a girl so bad i'm like
could be a girl you never know
good chance ours can be another one what
if but if the girl comes if a girl comes
she's also going to be a
monster athlete hopefully not hopefully
she'll look like me with a wig on
hopefully she looks like her mom
by the way but also she's gonna have two
bodyguards that's the thing that's the
absolute queen of the queen of the house
we i didn't have a girl i mean we had
three i had three other brothers so we
didn't have
i i don't know what it would have been
like but i think she would have been
protected by
all of us right my gr my girl goes wait
if we have a girl she's gonna be
wrapped around your finger like you're
you're gonna do anything from like
i do anything now for the bullet yeah
like if tiger's like dad i want this
i get you know that's just what do you
think's what i do
is that something the pushover debt like
are you a pushover oh
dude yeah big time do you think unless
it's sports
like we're like dude you got to get your
30 throws in like
or school i'm super strict but outside
that oh dude
do you think she'll be strict with like
curfew and where do you fall
like as of right now if your son is 16
and he's like hey i'm gonna have some
friends over you cool if we stay here
all night but we drink
where are you with that kind of stuff
nothing worse than the cool parent
yeah but there's nothing worse
but at the same time again you guys have
some weed but at the same time do you
want them
out drinking in drinking do you know
what i mean like that's
that's the thing i i i hope he
i ra he's raised where he's makes good
decisions where
you're gonna do that stuff but just do
it responsibly i think
to me i gave jacob an uber
card and i said i don't i never see a
charge on this that doesn't say uber
yes but like this is for
if you need a ride i'm never gonna
question it by the way even if it's two
in the afternoon i'm never gonna say why
did you need it so
take advantage and be safe yeah take
advantage of that but
if i ever hear about you getting in a
car
i'm gonna drive i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you yeah there was no
dude the madness i ever got at him i
found a vape in his room
uh tobacco how old was he fifteen or
sixteen
and i said to him i go the kids are
doing i said listen i'm gonna tell you
this and this is just your one
chance i'm gonna tell you this right now
do not
smoke vapes do not get addicted to this
[ __ ] no were you still smoking weed
every day when you're telling this yeah
but this he didn't know that
oh okay i'm like do not do not
and i'm serious man i can't get you
hooked on this this is
a hard habit to break and uh man
that [ __ ] and by the way yeah i
snoop in my kid's room
if you don't snoop in your kid's room
i'm a snooper and by the way and i
and i don't i didn't i didn't i snoop
around and yeah
everybody's gone
i'm a snooper i hear that's your studio
though yeah i know but
jen you got that i was like oh what's
this it's up for you
you're getting a gun huh okay you did
snoop
i'm a snooper you gotta snoop you gotta
see what's going on man
my thing with my kid is mcgee over here
oh snoop dogg she was trying to get a
gun
that's
is this i didn't bust him on everything
because i didn't want him to know i was
in his [ __ ]
yeah but i want to make sure he's not
doing things that are harmful to him
so as soon as i saw vape yeah you're
right and he goes away dave's bad though
he said to me he said
so where are you snooping in my room i
go no i was snooping in my room dude you
know that's
my room yeah i own this [ __ ] place
this whole place is my
[ __ ] yeah it was the madness i ever got
he i told him i said hey this was
towards the end of school i said i want
you to know when you
when school ends you're going to walk
home
you're going to this is in a school for
the summer you're going to walk into
your room
and you're not going to leave that room
until school starts in september jesus
christ
for for me telling him explicitly not to
if you do this again
yes you're not going to be happy with
the results that was my whole thing man
my whole thing was just making sure that
if i said i was going to do something
you have to follow otherwise they push
it like you that fourth
i tell my son don't do that otherwise
i'm not going to do this and then i do
it
yeah dude i [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
because he knows i'm going to give in
does he know that or you're easier than
hud
does he ask you instead of ask her every
time
and then he'll fake cry to me yeah you
better keep some cash in your pocket
if he's coming out if my girl yells at
him he'll come straight to me
she's like don't don't cuddle him do not
give him love i'm like
i gotta give him love what do you mean
not don't give him love
yeah he's coming over here she's like i
i'm always the bad guy i'm like
yeah bad cop
like nobody watches a movie with two bad
cops
yeah you're just playing it wrong yeah i
i
with the vaping like hopefully my kids
are you know if they want i can push
them into but if they're in sports like
for me the thing that kept me away from
vaping you even though
it wasn't available when i was kid but
cigarettes or weed or drugs or even
i didn't drink tubs you [ __ ] started
doing stand-up at all didn't drink at
all
but it was my dad was like yo so who do
you look up to
i'm like go junior seau or adam sandler
some athlete you know my dad was like
they don't do that stuff yeah buddy they
don't do that stuff
so if you want to be like them you're
gonna have to you don't do that stuff
and i was like oh yeah i want to be like
them so i'm not going to do it you
didn't drink in college
not barely because
i majored in football so it's like if we
were playing nebraska i didn't want to
get hammered
or i knew like if we played nebraska
especially when i started playing if we
played nebraska the following week was
missouri and they were studs and
i don't want you know i didn't want to
affect my do do do
i would i would like if like we would
we'd have like my buddy club and paul
creighton
um wheeled down and uh chad cuss with
like
they had a house and they'd have parties
they have kegs
and i drink like i play like beer pong
stuff but i never got i never got
hammered where you affect me never
when you thought i was gonna make the
nfl right
everybody does right we all did when
when you traveled with college football
do you ever party in the city you ever
no they take you and
bring you back right away fly in on a
friday night you're at the hotel you
have meetings that night
the next morning you're up early no
there's not a chance were you ever ready
to bowl game
oh yeah and everything yeah do they
party bowl games you can't a little more
but but there was there was guys
there was a guy who went on to be
drafted and he was a stud for the
cowboys for the
cleveland browns and before a game uh
my buddy who's also a first round pick
in the second round
he had to sleep on a couch because we
played in the houston ball
and our buddy is from houston and he
just every hour he had a new girl
he's just [ __ ] all through the night
all through the night
played horrible the next day played
horrible
missed the blitz yeah no [ __ ] got my
buddy joel clatten literally
ended his career got knocked out because
know he missed the blitz he just missed
it
and i want to be like [ __ ] he was he
was like he got no sleep
yeah i want to i want to tattle on him
but i didn't but i'm like
oh yeah he missed the blitz because he
was up all night [ __ ]
this has to be a stick of information
those legs
your legs are a little jelly you always
you got no sleep man he had the worst
game ever
i was like dude you're [ __ ] all night
like what do you think was gonna happen
now he went again he went on to have a
great career though
by the way i'm gonna i'm gonna go on
record right now and i'm gonna tell you
say what you want
joe clyde you know what i'm talking
about but i i literally got knocked out
dude i'm gonna go on record right now
played utep
[ __ ] all night sounds at my age i'm
terrible
exhausting when i hear people like we
[ __ ] for hours i'm like wow why
what are we talking about yeah i i'm not
in the gym forever
hours exhausting when i people are like
brag about it i'm like bro
you must you need to go to a doctor or
something hours sounds like
it just doesn't sound interesting for
hours not my thing no you don't know
like three hour movies no
no no so you're not this that time
served it seems like
when i hear guys brag about it i'm like
dude that first of all
also who's bragging also by the way uh
i i've never been a woman before but i'm
assuming
after at least an hour of sex
i mean it's gonna sound like it's good
it's gonna sound like sneakers at the
ymca on the gr yeah
i've never tried it i'm not against it i
looked into trt by the way
uh did you see a doctor i saw a doctor
and
get your levels checked got my levels
checked i'm getting them i should get
them back oh so you don't know what
they're at
but i bet with how lean you are but your
testosterone is pretty high
and your energy's good right yeah is
that because i don't i'm not
accumulating a lot of body fat
and i think that so low body fat high
energy that's you that's all
testosterone based usually because
usually males after 40 of testosterone
that's one of the main things for
depression stuff like that and
fat like you when your testosterone
drops you're you're
your happiness everything muscle mass
everything drops
and you you're not like do you suffer i
was thinking i don't know why i was
thinking about this last night i can't
sleep because my kid almost died but um
you do you suffer from depression at all
i was thinking about this last night
yeah do you
yeah i knew it yeah which is weird
because i've never seen it out of you
no but first well every last time like i
bet josh suffers from different yeah
yeah i go i have i have um i have some
dark spells i really do have some dark
spells
and uh how dark are we talking have you
and were you always like this
because depression is like because cat's
been oh i'm not saying anything
that cat hasn't said on air i'm not iron
or laundry but cat suffers from
depression too
but i can tell right when cat when cat
yeah you have a really you walk in i'm
like
cat yeah cat as uh dove davidoff would
say has a touch of the dog
yeah i mean my dad used to say that guy
has a touch of the downs
oh yeah he'd be like that guy looks like
he was just good god gave him just a
touch the hilarious yeah
if you had depression your dad would say
no no no he would oh just in general if
he's
if you think he'll be like that stupid
touch of the downs that's funny
um but not like he was not like full but
like god was like here you're just a
little just a touch
yeah i feel you i i would tell you in
public
the days that you see me the happiest
i'm overcompensating
um i'm over compensating and have you
always been you've always struggled with
depression i don't know how to answer
that because i think when i was younger
i'm not sure i knew
i would have i would identify like would
you wake up sad though when you're
younger
um yeah some
it's been because they they say it is
like uh
it's a genetic right yeah so there's a
good chance your kids are probably gonna
suffer from it
so i think for sure that um
jacob has a little bit of it i i mean my
daughter has her
already had we have has her issues for
me
uh my oldest son i don't know i i don't
think he does he's going through some
tough times but i don't know if he
technically has a military kid
yeah but but for me man on medication
am i no i
my depression is always about it always
comes down to and i don't know about you
cat
but it it's such self-loathing
and it's got nothing to do with anything
around me it's never depressed about my
career it's never depressed about my
family
it's i hit a period of a couple days
where i just think i'm the biggest piece
of [ __ ]
and i just same with you cat yeah it's
really hard
for me ain't nothing you can do huh i
can't shake it at him i can't
shake it out of my own the only thing
that keeps me
sane is i'm old enough
and i've been through it enough to know
you'll get through it this is going to
end
this is not good i know when you're when
you have the touch of the dog
uh beth does my wife does she knows what
they do
growing up do the kids notice no because
you know
um like i said i'm pretty good
of overcompensating but the more i
overcompensate the worse i feel about
myself
that makes sense so the happier i
pretend to be the more the
deeper the fall do you have depression
chin no
i suffered from anxiety for like a few
years but then i kind of went away you
have anxiety but
do you do you get attacks uh define
attack
your heart races you sweat uh you feel
like you're gonna have a heart attack
none of that have attacked it's just
like a kind of a cut if it scale one to
ten would be a
four throughout the week oh that's not
terrible three four or five
i mean you just you're like oh come on
dude but does it does it does it
interfere with your
day-to-day like does it doesn't no power
no
you know i might lose sleep or i might
be not present at home when it happens
why did you think that i have no idea
yeah i knew it though
i don't know i was like i bet because i
have so many friends that suffer from oh
god i bet josh has depression well
one of the things and one of the reasons
why i really focus on
being positive and and um
and lifting myself and other people up
and not focusing on negative
and is because if if i sink it it's easy
for me to sink into it
like for me to remember to stay positive
does it happen once a month for you
honestly when i can when i can mentally
keep up with myself and try to remind
myself about things that i do have and
things not things that i don't have
things that i can do and not things that
i can't do
i can really help myself but at least
i would say once every six weeks or so
it just hits
hard it's a gut punch do you miss shows
no i've never missed anything
i've never missed anything i've had
crying fits in the green room because i
would get off stage and just be like you
suck nobody should
i always have to clean it clear it out
but but i
i and i don't feel like you haven't had
a spell in a wild cat
do you take medication i do not take
medication i don't know it i've been
depressed since i met you though
like i've been depressed for the last
like two years to a certain level though
yeah to a certain level it's always
pretty manageable and then every couple
of months i'll get it'll get bad
it'll get really bad and how many days
it lasts for you
uh usually a couple weeks see mine
doesn't don't last that long and is it
for you
is it self-loathing is it or is it more
about
i don't know everything just feels
really great it's like i don't feel
anything it's
weird it's almost like everything's
heavy yeah everything's heavy
everything's like very
gray i have like no motivation to do
anything
to do something you don't want to talk
about anybody i don't know how to
explain this but things almost
sound different it's sound everything
sounds so
monotone and just medication can help
with that
cat you don't want to try it out no why
not try it out though i don't i don't
like the idea of taking me either
medicine for if i don't need to me too
in my head like if i've already gotten
to this point in my life
without medication i know well enough
that there are certain things i can do
to help it it may never
like take care of the issue but i don't
want to but what if and i don't know
i have no i'm talking about my ass here
but i know people that suffer from it
who are very close to me and they're on
medication it really helps
it helps a lot of people but does it i
think my
my thing is that like i've heard some
people say it just dulls me out yep i've
heard that
and so i've heard some people were like
oh i wouldn't be on this earth if i
didn't have it
and it's great and i've heard from other
people especially creatives like oh it
makes me
that's the thing i don't mind hitting
that
hole for three or four days every six
weeks or so
i'm just scared that it could that it
will just dull me out
what if it makes you guys awesome i mean
if you've been doing deal
since i've known you you know what i'm
saying and it's really really bad for
weeks
it's been like that since i was like a
kid though weird
yeah your parents were never like
emotional
no they i don't think they really even
allowed to see other people how's she
gonna see a dog
they didn't know it was like an issue
until i was like 18.
genetically it's something with a
chemical imbalance for you yeah like my
sister has something
my sister has it too uh my sister's
bipolar can you feel it coming on when
it happens
yeah i can kind of feel it trickling in
yeah and and do you almost prepare
yourself mentally
yeah i just i kind of give people a
heads up like hey if i disappear for a
couple weeks
like you don't hear from me i'm fine i
tell you they'll like check into the
podcast and make sure that
i'm at work and i'm like if i'm at work
i'm good does it does it
affect you going places do you miss work
do you miss work but she's not she
i can't when it's a bad food cat she's
not
she's not cat you know you're just like
ah [ __ ] yeah
it's so impossible to explain to people
because you're an intelligent person i'm
half intelligent i know when i'm in it
i know when i'm in it and i'm like i'm
in it just get yourself
out of it and it just doesn't happen one
of my closest friends my brother theo
vaughn and
i'm not saying yeah that's not out there
he suffers from it yeah
and dude you're talking jekyll and
[ __ ] hide men
where i'm learning to deal with it more
now but
it was i mean he'll get dark and
this is the worst and this i'm like what
the [ __ ] and then you realize oh that's
not real
and what he's saying he doesn't mean
it's not real you know
or sometimes you know in the morning he
might be as worse so mean him
theo and i don't talk before 11 a.m we
don't because we'd
always fight yeah he'd be like oh dude
and then
at one he'd call and apologize i'm like
dude let's just not talk in the mornings
like let's just skip that don't call me
about any business or anything regarding
the show
we'll just talk later in the afternoon
you're much better he's like i agree
and then but when theo is happy he's the
best [ __ ] person
on the planet [ __ ] yeah he's one of my
favorite people on this earth
when he's sad i know and i force him to
come to my house
i go t i go theo i guarantee you cannot
be sat around tiger
guarantee it dude just come over see
what happens and you're not
he won't do it and he'll come over no he
can't he don't have time to think about
his shitty situation whatever he's going
through because tiger is forced to play
hide and go seek
or shoot [ __ ] nerf guns or drag him
to the pool or basketball
and he'll be like dude this really
helped like tell me dude i think
i didn't notice it as much when my kids
were younger and maybe also because
it was all depression when i was when i
was living in that one
room with them it all kind of sucked
it'd be tough so
i i don't know and maybe just everything
was happening all at once
but the more time alone i've had as
they've gotten older
is the more i've really noticed it i
think social media if you do suffer from
that amplifies everything too i agree
with you there's not a lot of positivity
going on there
we can find it but for in general if
you're going through calm and stuff like
that like
no no successful person is leaving
comments comments so you're
you're getting comments from people who
are not happy
yeah and they're suffering from whatever
you're suffering for and they lash out
on there and you're reading those
comments
and you're downloading that into your
database it's not good man well also
for those of us in this business and
anything really
when you look at social media you think
you're looking at people's
actual lives no they're just showing you
the parts that they want you to see so
no matter when you're scrolling through
all you're looking
at is people who you perceive to have a
better life than you
yes and it's not real no it's everyone's
struggling super depressing
everyone has the same problems too dude
yeah whether it's a person
taking a picture in a giant mansion they
still have problems trust me or
blizzarians get their problems
who i heard blizzarians got some dan i
heard
i heard he had some i somebody told me
that
they were coming after him for tax stuff
i could have told you he has problems
from his [ __ ] instagram
you do you don't post pictures with dime
pieces and guns and tanks and you want
your money like that not have
serious issues yeah serious ego
issues self-doubt jacob's worked a
couple problems he has a little dick
you know like you don't and i like him
you don't post that stuff
because you're you're you're throwing
this out there for
not just for followers you're doing
something with this dude yeah man you
know
i i've never been to one of those
parties jacob's been to a couple where
he worked a couple and he said it's like
you know those parties you see in the
movies that you don't think actually
happen
he was like that's what his parties are
like and i said how and he said but
um he was like there's just so but i
didn't know this until i looked
i think that he they pay for a lot of
those
women to be there i think 100 percent i
had no idea
oh yeah so the the that party alone must
cost
a gazillion casa gazillion also no one
knows each other you ever been to a
party right now how do you know me i
don't like
well that's weird you go over here how
do you know oh we don't he just invited
me
it's like an old brian callum party i'd
go up i'm like oh how do you guys know
each other we don't
okay how do you guys venture we don't
nobody knows each other do you know
whose house this is like
no brian just invited random people
and there's no chemistry there's no
there's no vibe in the party like what
the [ __ ] is a bunch of rejects
dude i was at a party okay
long time ago party in seattle
small party maybe like 14 people
and this girl that we know that i used
to work with
she's having sex with a dude in the room
at my friend's room
and they have sex and dude has a couple
more drinks and high fives people it was
funny because there aren't many people
there so you know people are [ __ ]
right
and walks out and we know the girl and
she comes out and she was i just
couldn't help it we were like yeah no
problem get your [ __ ] on
and she was like this was so funny she
was like i didn't really know him whose
friend is that
and we were like we thought you brought
nobody
knew who the [ __ ] guy was he came out
high-fived everybody took a couple shots
and left we were like got his rocks
he went home was like dude i was walking
down the street nobody knew this i saw a
party
went in this hot chick [ __ ] her
drank their drinks and left dude on the
high were they cool
pretty cool yeah dude i was like i was
thinking the same thing i'm like that's
the best night that dude has ever had
ever he's probably still telling the
story now he's like i i
you to to be walking home or whatever
even if you're and if i think i know the
pressure talk about
smoking hot crazy dude
crazy he must have lived in the building
or something
like i like parties yeah i'm gonna swing
by here and she's hot
let's do this what a great night yeah
let me take a piss ready
sure oh man you stinky kids i got some
for you i'm talking about native
deodorant doesn't just block
odor better it's made better native has
ingredients you've heard of like coconut
oil
shea butter they got all sorts of tasty
stuff for you and guess what
no aluminum that's going to plug your
sweat glands and kill you we don't have
any of that stuff man we're talking
aluminum free deodorant
and also it doesn't mean you you stink
if there's no aluminum no no
native will keep you smelling and
feeling fresh all day long
we got 10 cents for your ass we got the
most popular scents i'm talking about
coconut vanilla
lavender and rose my favorites the
cucumber and mint we got it all native
is risk free to try
every product comes with free shipping
within the us of a plus
free 30-day returns exchanges see why so
many people love native
check out the over 14 000 five-star
reviews it's what i use every day
do what i did and make the switch in
native today by going to native
nativedeo.com
t-fat k or use the promo code t-fat k at
check out and get 20
off your first order that's native
deo.com
t-fat k or use the promo code t-fat k at
check out for 20
off your first order this episode is
brought to you by on it the one
and only the best supplements on planet
earth what do you need kids
what the frick do you need to stay
healthy to get in shape
lose those quarantine 20. we got earth
grown nutrients we got protein powder
for you
we got it all we got freaking alpha
brain for you podcasters or stand-up
comedians out there how about you need
some fitness gear
the stores are sold out because
everybody's trying to get in shape
during quarantine
not on it we got freaking kettlebells we
got
freaking battle ropes we got sandbags
steel maces
we got oh uh on-demand training you can
do it from your freaking cell phone in
your garage in your living room in your
hotel room whatever you need
on it six streaming fitness available
right now
we got coffee the [ __ ] yeah coffee from
black rifle
and onyx collab they got caffeinated
crystals
[ __ ] yeah coffee black rifle on it save
10 off it's my favorite coffee on
com slash fighter for 10 off that's on
it.com
fighter 10 off you're welcome and up
until beth
i've only ever dated asian women oh
interesting pretty much since college
only asian one
and then beth was like a total departure
from it but i don't really have a type
my type's hot
i don't give a [ __ ] what what ethnicity
hot's hot
i don't care i don't discriminate no i i
like that ever i like
white asian eop you have an equal
opportunity penis
hot as hot dude yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
i like all
were you your wife is hispanic super
mexican
is this the first annoying mexican yeah
even when they're like so mexican like
jesus christ when she gets mad at you
does she speak to you in spanish
she speaks to the kidness man she can
talk to me smash but i don't understand
any of it so i don't care what if the
kids
and her start talking spanish they do
about you
they do i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
well you don't care you get your [ __ ] by
the way the worst of when they go bad on
white people i'm like
hey man i'm right here i'm here i'm
standing and then i have to make an
argument for white people like
all right we can do this if you want man
i'm gonna destroy you guys
i'm going to hurt some feelings in here
here's what there's some feelings up in
this [ __ ]
here's what i really want to see i want
to work here at mom's house for
for like her mama make uh you know to
come up for christmas and they have like
uh i think it's called uh
i forget what's called oh uh posole
it's this is frank yeah it's like pisoli
or minuto it's a posole
menudo has some but interesting stuff
it's posole but it's like uh
for you white people out there don't
know it's a mexican soup
and it's but it's not hearty but it's a
soup right
and they'll eat that for christmas i'm
dude at 37 i'm 255.
i'm starving that's an appetizer i'm
like i can't have soup as a meal
and it's all they'll eat it like three
or four i'm like no no no
no we're gonna whiten it up around here
we're gonna whiten it up
this is what i did we're gonna whiten it
up i'm not having soup so they have
their soup
dude i called a service to drop off ham
turkey
stuffing cranberry sauce gravy what did
they eat
they they're [ __ ] soup but my kids
i'm like new
kids i don't know what the [ __ ] this the
soup that's not how we do it in america
you have some [ __ ] my son's like
stuffing
yeah i'm like hey hey man
listen i know half of you loves the soup
but half of you
has got to eat turkey and watch football
buddy and i ain't talking about
[ __ ] soccer i'm gonna tell you
something else right now
good stuffing ah by the way gravy
stuffing can be
terrible oh yeah or can be if it's good
it's the best thing at thanksgiving
a good stuffing by the way i feel the
same way about uh bread pudding
bread pudding you ever had that dessert
it's my favorite dessert name of the day
probably had it josh bread pudding can
also be the worst
a nice bread pudding in a dark coffee
my problem is it's more like i'm trying
to push the american culture on my kids
because
they're in my entire household is
engulfed in mexican culture
everything's about the music around the
house the mexican
food is probably better if you had to
pick
one nationality's food to eat america
really oh dude barbecue a nice [ __ ]
rib for the rest of your life for the
rest of your life and cheese only one
steak i go makeovers if you said you can
pick
one food for the rest of your life
america not a mexican breakfast
mexican for sure for me mexican
breakfast breakfast is fantastic when my
mother-in-law when i wake up you go
american over italian
or japanese yeah and you can leave this
goddamn country
these are fighting words dude
[Applause]
i don't give a [ __ ] dude a nice steak
and like some asparagus
okay steak bacon eggs in the morning
dude
scrambled eggs with cheddar cheese well
i guess with americans it gets
a nice oatmeal dude so i guess we'd have
to just
define what american is but you haven't
hit anything
like what's american dude what's
american but if you go breakfast
a [ __ ] a nice sandwich in the
afternoons
with some lace chips over easy eggs with
some refried beans and a tortilla
and some guac and salsa
calm the [ __ ] on and i'll put an
enchilada up
against a piece of steak any day a good
enchilada
i'll put that up against it my favorite
a nice mole a real nice mole
chicken mole
my girl makes the best [ __ ] mole
don't tease that [ __ ]
and then she makes spanish rice with it
oh my god
dude there was a guy that worked in my
kitchen there's no
canned salsa in my house there's only
fresh meats every morning
it's so mexican by the way that's like
people who pour their there's
tomato sauce out of a [ __ ] jar like
america come on man yeah i know it's bad
there was a guy i
had a bar in bar restaurant seattle
called el lobo loco
you had a bar yeah it was your bar oh
okay you own a bar terrible business
idea okay
so i i worked in seattle this is when i
was starting with brody and joey
and i worked at a bar and it was run by
these two asian guys a japanese guy and
a korean guy
um aki and uh i forget the korean guy's
name
the korean guy was part of the korean
mop
oh wow and one day aki said to me hey
i forget his name he's not he's not
coming back yet
and i was like where is he and he was
like he's just not coming back
so i was like ooh so the business
started to go down a little bit and he
goes i'm going to close and he had a ton
of money
and i said do me a favor man give me six
months
to turn your place around and if i turn
your place around i was in pioneer
square
let me just get a piece of your business
do you have any history of running a bar
i've bartended before doesn't count
right yeah so i go get let me turn the
business around give me six months
basically i just want to six more months
of a job is what i want sure i said but
if i turn it around and hit this
you give me i'm gonna ask for a piece of
the business smart
i turned it around because he was
basically not
the one he wasn't doing anything he had
in downtown seattle
he had these authentic uh these dudes
straight from mexico
who cooked great mexican food cooking
these 50
tacos and stuff 50 lunches for
businessmen in seattle
no i said we need money in and out yeah
let's get it's a lunch rush
and i said these guys make mexican food
this dude made the best mole
now he brought his brother in from
mexico his brother had one glass eye
because he had been stabbed in it oh
yeah
but this dude made us some great [ __ ]
food bro but
they played one of the best tricks on me
they had me cut jalapenos
and i didn't know you i had never cut
jalapenos and then taken a leak have you
ever done that before oh yeah
in fuego your dick was in fuego i
they were laughing for an extended
period of time but
man we at this place called the lobo
loco
and uh i forget why i started talking
about this you turned the bar around
mexican food mole started oh the mole
oh so these guys made these this guy
made this mole that was so [ __ ] dope
so he did turn around so he turned it
around
because i asked you a few he gave me 15
this is what i asked him for i go
i want 15 this was an ask that i didn't
think you'd give me
off the top i want 15 of what you bring
in before you pay anybody else you pay
me 15
and he was like okay because he already
had he was going to shut down anyway got
to shut down he had a ton of money not
gonna do it
dude do you papa was balling i ended up
making
i used to walk around with this wad of
just cash
my rent was i was sharing a place with
another comic
a guy named craig gass lived in my place
i think i paid 750 dollars a
a month and right such a bargain dude i
was bawling up in seattle
i love seattle he threw and i went out
of town one weekend to do some stand up
and he threw an underage party
yeah aki was like yeah man he and his
was i go dude i saw the flyer i go this
says
18 and over he said yeah but it's for
asian people so the cops won't care and
i'm like
i don't think that's how it works it
works and he was like yeah they won't
care because it's underage
asian people in america so we're
definitely yeah that was his
in america i think there were a few of
those where i grew up
too under 18 parties
it was like an asian owned club they had
one night out of the month where it was
just 18 and under yes
but he said he was like yeah they won't
care because they're asian people and i
was like why do you [ __ ] mind
i came back he was like oh they closed
us down we're not allowed to open up
ever again
and that's why you guys went down that
was it that was the end of that that was
such a [ __ ] run
i hired joe diaz i have you talked to
joey since he moved
man i have talked about that that's my
guy man you know
i'm so genuinely
happy for him brendan i never thought he
would be alive right now
i if he's thriving he's one of the
biggest comics in the world dude i
never thought he would be alive
there was a period of time years
three or four years where he was close
to 400 pounds so he's probably 280 now
he's not small no he's not small but
let's add 120 pounds
working out still he was close to 400
pounds he was probably doing an eight
ball a day yeah
he had these open wounds on his face
that he would pick that never healed
yeah
and he would he was this crazy gray
color
yeah and i was just like oh not only is
he not going to live
he's slowly trying to i'm surprised you
and rogan never got close because him
and joey are so close you know like him
and joey are close
you know i was like a weird separation i
don't know
because obviously me and joe's one of my
closest friends you and me are supe
here's here's here's the thing you know
it's like how the [ __ ] haven't we
there was a big there was a big gap when
chelsea was on
and where can you enjoy no just between
me
and stand-up in town because i was
working on the show and traveling
and my deal was i'm not also now going
out at night
and doing standards
i wonder if it correlates with the same
time rogan because rogan was gone for a
while too when he's doing
fair factor he was gone for a little bit
that was during the mencia time too
and but but because of that
and when stand-ups started to really
cook again i was still out a little bit
and i don't think people who are on that
show
in general got a lot of
respect as stand-ups interesting well it
sounds like jealousy
even whatever yeah because that show was
so big it was pretty it's weird to me
when i have close friends like you
like joe coy when like joko is not in
the circle of my
friends and i always i want to bring
them into the circle
i think a lot of people was like what
yeah yeah i texted him yesterday i go
hey dude come do the show with me and
josh he goes love josh
he goes dude i'm shooting this and sent
me a video he's shooting a kia
commercial right now
and we're talking about someone killing
it he's just like this is a second
reference with you and kia remember
we're making fun of people
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
he was like i'm shooting this for kia
he's like
he was keying something else major i'm
like dude do you ever stop
crushing it he's so he he sold out
staples
yeah oracle [ __ ]
where their warriors play he's a monster
it is bananas he's the best guy in the
world he's such a good guy
his hustle man i respect
anybody do you know joe that well yeah
man his hustle is
cause he was on chelsea too right yeah
and i remember him standing in front of
that laugh factory dude when nobody knew
who he was
bad teeth and all do you mind girls
trying to let me get veneers
and joe you're gonna hate this sorry
buddy my girl goes look at your friend
joe
show me a picture of joe before the
veneers and after rough sauce dude
oh before i was like were you chewing on
[ __ ] glass yeah yeah and then now
like he's great teeth yeah he definitely
was
was somebody who benefited from the
money whoever has money to make bring
happiness look at joe coy
he looks like [ __ ] before the money now
he's happy as [ __ ] his teeth are great
he's lost weight he was he's he wears
shoes like all the like
dope kicks yeah dude that dude is
definitely is as far as a sneaker [ __ ]
he's the only person i think that from
you uh
sneaker horse joe coy it's deleo
me dele is the other biggest thinker
biggest sneaker head i know
yeah they they uh how much the veneers
cost there you go 2 500 per tooth that's
insane well my girl said this guy
offered the deal
two for two teeth for 1500 i'm like
you're just gonna do two teeth well
that's what i'm going to look pretty
[ __ ] with here i just can do the
front two
she's like no you'd have to do you know
you have to pay for 10.
it's like 13 grand also don't get a deal
for your teeth
that doesn't sound good okay like a deal
for lasik eyes
yeah like don't do can i tell you the
one and only flicker i
ever got i was in you got a hooker oh
yeah okay
i was in las vegas and my brother you
know when they hand out the
flyers right you guys took him so i i
was like
like oh look at this [ __ ] man i go this
is crazy they're handing them out like
it's a menu he goes it is a menu
and i said i don't even know who who
calls off a menu and he goes you've
never had a hooker before i go no
and he goes you've never had a hooker
and i was like am i
how old are you am i weird pre-marriage
so
probably 28 sure and i was like no i've
never had a
because i i never felt like i needed to
get a lady of them i was
28 i was still young and
i had to get a girl yeah i wasn't too
worried i paid for it yeah
but he was like you got to do it before
you like he has to be an experienced a
little
right so we call this
uh i call this place and i say to him i
go what am i gonna do though man i said
you're in the room
i don't wanna [ __ ] in front of you and
he was like i'll go to sleep
and i was like you you're gonna go to
sleep he said yeah i'll go to sleep
so we call this place dude and it was
late
and um i said so i don't know how to do
this she said what are you looking for i
said well what do you got
she said well it's late so we only have
two girls left but they're completely
different oh you got the leftovers
she said they're completely different so
you should be able to pick
and just let me know if either one of
these are interesting to you i said okay
did you see those pictures
it was just what was on the flyer and i
go tell me who you got she said we
either have
a petite asian or a giant puerto rican
petite asian
well and i said to my brother i go
petite asian giant puerto rican
and he goes what do you think and i was
like well i've had sex with a petite
asian that's all i used to date yeah but
it's awesome
but i've never even seen a giant puerto
rican
reason i told her i go send the giant
puerto rican over
oh wow she oh dude i played a deal
[ __ ] red rover red rover send the
giant puerto rican on over to
[ __ ] so i tell my brother i got a giant
puerto rican coming over
he was like great i would say define
giant puerto rican well
i so i said i'd go giant like 300 pounds
and she was like no just a big person
giant a giant's so big
so my brother hookers take longer than
room service but you know when you order
a quesadilla and you fall asleep before
it gets there yeah
that you say they wake you up in a deep
sleep yeah and you're like i don't want
i don't want the
[ __ ] in case i need to sleep so but i
hear this little knock
and i'm like yo josh
you know what i hear a little knock and
i was like hey i'm not going to get it
maybe i was like i was like maybe
they'll go away okay so ready
but then the knock went like harder and
i'm like oh that sounds like a big
person
and now you know i like weird [ __ ] man
now my curiosity's peaked i'm like well
i'm going to look through the people
because i want to see what this person
looks like before i open the door yeah
so i sneak up and i look at the peephole
and there's a thumb over the people
oh and i hear this like a big dark thumb
i hear this i hear
you gotta open the door to see the goods
and the first thing i thought was
veteran that's somebody who's been
rejected through a people 100
that's somebody's somebody's real vet
somebody's looking at people i've been
like
[ __ ] up beat it sammy sosa
i'm waiting for a quesadilla beat it
reuben ramirez
yeah so but i'm like
i really now at this point my brother's
asleep i really just want to see what a
giant puerto rican is you're probably
horny right
but now horny horny of you know if
you're thinking you get your rocks
but also curio for me we weird trumps
almost like if if this is gonna be a
good story i gotta open the door i might
give you a bit on stage
my only when i hear a giant puerto rican
in my head i'm thinking
good chance it's transgender okay well i
opened the door
probably six two in heels
so the first thing i looked for is an
adam's apple because i was like well
this
that's a giveaway yeah no bad adam's
apple do you know the next thing i asked
and she was like how you doing i go good
i go hey do you mind if i take a look at
your knuckles
because man hands in women's hands man
hand and women hands knuckles are are a
dead giveaway yeah
and hand out i'm like oh okay well you
can't even feel just from the hands but
there was no it was
a woman and i go okay just a big girl
big girl so
big puerto rican this is what i was
talking about you don't want to chance
on your
dentist i'll i'll skip past
the uncomfortable parts of the story to
tell you when she took
off her bra she had one
big titties one real one one fake one oh
and i go what
she goes like i couldn't afford to get
them both done at the same time
so my doctor did one and when i healed
up i'm gonna do another i think i'm here
[ __ ]
bro but i was like yo she goes most
people don't hate it's not distracting
i'm like
oh my god her left titty looked like it
had just had a stroke oh
like her left titty looked like
stallone's lip the original one yeah
just so yeah just like
sagging down another one pretty nice
yeah the other one looked great and the
other one looked sad
yeah body pretty body pretty messy
body not terrible dude but she's a big
girl did something to me
that ruined it for me we were we had
just done a little banter back and forth
and she wouldn't tell me what was in her
bag when she dropped her bag on the
desk it made such a loud thud she was
carrying a bowling
something heavy was in there and i asked
her as a joke gun
i said what's in the bag and she said
don't worry about what's in the bag and
i was like oh
[ __ ] probably a gun right or a giant
dildo i don't know what's in there
she this is what scared me she at one
point
she said let's [ __ ] and she pushed me
two hand pushed to the chest
what scared me dude is she knocked me
clean over onto the bed and i was like
the undertaker yeah i was like i'm about
to get [ __ ]
like i'm about this is a not me doing
cbd
yeah this is your chris rocky [ __ ] this
is not good for me
and i find i stood up i go i can't do
this i i'm sorry i can't do this well
you backed out she charged me extra
wasting our [ __ ] time for wasting
your time that i didn't have
and then my brother cracked his eye open
he goes i got two hundred dollars you
get to the [ __ ] out of the room i'm like
have you been awake this whole time he
was like
yeah i wanted to see you two [ __ ]
giant puerto ricans you didn't think
you'd be asleep right
so your brother your brother my brother
gave her the extra money bullet because
what she said to me was
if you don't give me this extra money
i'm going to make a phone call
and you're not going to like who shows
up because i can get dark in here dude
i couldn't beat up the giant puerto
rican there's no way i could beat up the
person who beats up the giant puerto
rican who slaps puerto rican around
there's no way so my brother was like
get her out of here paid and your
brother paid 200 went to
went to pound town no he kicked her out
he just paid her the was like get the
[ __ ] out oh okay i thought you've seen
your brother said
get out he was he was like first of all
i would have gotten a teeth
giant well he said 100 100 i would have
gone petite aged
but it's so many reasons he said as soon
as you said giant puerto rican i knew he
was like well i got it
i got to see yeah stay awake i got to
see what a giant puerto rican looks like
and that's what it came down to
i don't want you a giant puerto rican
you don't want to see you've seen a
petite asian
yeah but that's why my dick would like
i'm in
but giant puerto rican my big girl i'm
out but couldn't you also be in
like what if she was like giant puerto
rican meaning like 5
10 like an l mcpherson giant like curvy
giant
elle mcpherson has got to be five ten
five if they say
giant puerto rican come out dude i've
never heard anyone refer to a sexy curvy
girl as
giant how tall six foot you wouldn't
call
six foot look at her but no one's gonna
call ellen mcfirst she's such a dime no
one's gonna say she's
no yeah i don't choose that
feet or that there's no way if she's
tall dude that guy has to be shorter
than me then because that looks like me
standing next to brendan
that does look by the way that looks
like mine in your picture after all our
podcast
so big i'm so big look at that look that
looks sort of real
that looks real i think she is
i don't know what that was going on one
of the all-time he's just tall girls
with short dudes how tall is
that i think it's just a good thing
these are photoshopped just a good
could you date a real tall chick yeah i
don't have those issues that's not i
wouldn't bother me
but i mean but tall for how tall because
you mean taller than me or taller than
you
you're like would you date a six five
girl
again dude my type is hot if she's six
five i don't know
i have no problem i don't care i really
i i
remember i was in the room with serena
williams was warming up and i'm like
i get it oh my god dude and even i was
like i'm a little light in the ass for
her
she's so my ex the mother of my kids
big girl not a finn a bit but like would
you say
giant no no she was not as tall but
if your story ended and then we got
married and we got married and had three
kids
three kids she but my ex i've dated some
heavier girls that doesn't bot that's
not a thing that doesn't bother me at
all yeah you're not worried about the
thick girl
i i like it if i like you i like you me
too almost doesn't matter
but if sometimes the personalities can
make them super hot if we're talking
about
i'm meeting you at the bar and we're
going to have sex
then i do want to be very attracted to
you if i'm going to spend an extended
period of time with you
your looks are less important to me
interesting because i want to be able to
you know there's some people out there
to check all those boxes yeah my wife
yeah there you go that's why she's wifey
yeah that's why i'm allowed but but but
for me
looks go down a little bit because i got
we're not going to be [ __ ]
all of the time so it can't just be like
you'll be cool can't wait for us to [ __ ]
oh i know
that's going to be about yeah like you
and your girl like to joke around and
all that [ __ ]
right yeah the same stuff she's a beast
of a mom
yeah does she did she keep you in check
like as far as like
i don't think anybody can does she
no no do you
does she so she has she but she's also
super strong-willed so we'll butt hey
got it got it got it got it got it got
it but also kind of works because if you
let me just walk all over you i'll do it
and she doesn't allow me to do that when
you say that you do it just because
it's your instinct just to do what you
want to do or because you
do want to sleep because you or because
you're consciously like i'm gonna walk
over this morning oh never
but if you give me an inch i'm taking a
mile my girl won't let me do that and
that's why we work
yeah i feel the same way with it's not
good does she call you on your [ __ ] oh
yeah
it's not good if i'm staring the ship
all the time no
i mean it's also exhausting for me
everyone on the ship is going to be
wearing kerchiefs
yeah yeah everyone's going to be in the
same shoes and [ __ ] yeah everyone's
yeah i
i if i didn't have beth
to tell me that's [ __ ] dumb don't do
that
or you know don't do this while you're
in public or
just act like a [ __ ] grown-up for
once yep i don't know
what would happen to me i agree i'm yeah
thank god let's go to current events
all right i mean you know the best i
feel like i feel like you need a kind of
a passive guy
a passive guy why i don't know you're
pretty strong willed
yeah that's fair i don't know i don't
like guys who are too passive though
like my ex to a certain point he just
kind of let me walk all over him
that's not sexy what's your type it's
not uh
i don't know i used to really like nerdy
asians
yeah nerdy asian i used to really like
nerdy asian dudes i
do still like them but i get white guys
now it's weird
like i really honestly never thought i'd
date a white guy not that i don't think
white guys are attractive it's just i've
always loved
asian dudes dude nerdy asians you're
types nerdy asian but is your type just
hot too
i know uh if a guy can make me laugh if
i enjoy your company then that's all
that really matters because i can think
someone's gonna hide the looks
huh even if they look like they have to
be relatively
like i have to be relatively attracted
to them but i can see a hot person not
want to spend any time with that what's
more important
face or body uh
i'm gonna go well if we're talking still
in like mo
like just still like a regular dude yeah
like
how fat interesting there is
there are guys that i think are cute but
like a little tubby and i'm okay with it
but jonah hill jonah jonah hill when
he has a good question yeah yeah dude i
was sitting next to him
at a coffee shop and he was on a blind
date
joan hill yeah and i was like i'm going
to stay here because this is so
interesting
yeah i just stood there and listened to
his blind date wait there wasn't i want
to be like dude not a match
blind date so she knows who he it's not
really a blind date for her
[ __ ] it's kind of sounded like it they
were sharing books
and she went to the bathroom i wanted to
be like dude come on man come on dude
you're jonah hill she sucks i yeah if
i'm jonah hill i don't think i need to
what's that dating app for the famous
people here in town
right right yeah a bunch of my buddies
are on there and do they
show me the girls like holy [ __ ] but
she's on there you have to be
accepted on that app you have to apply
yeah and then for the men you have to
send
basically your tax returns to prove that
you have the money you have
i mean it's just do you have to earn a
certain amount of money to be on that
you do or a certain level of fame and my
buddy like i don't know what's going on
dude i just can't find a connection like
he yeah dude you're on raya so it's just
gold diggers trying to find a [ __ ]
mat have you seen like get off of there
have you seen the women are famous women
on there
because i might one of my favorite my
friends is on there my favorite thing is
to go through it
i mean i had heard some of the instagram
models that we see the famous ones are
on there you're like
come on i had somebody to tell me
celebrity aaron stone on right oh yeah
oh yeah
some of the biggest start big stars are
on there no
stars from shows we watch like holy [ __ ]
that guy's you're like i saw him on
yellowstone
dude i i hope you graduate to hat
lasso and like rocking horse yeah so
you're on the [ __ ] rocking horse
right get in there dude i might send you
a rocking horse i'm getting there
all right let's do it what do we got
okay so a
man or woman in jamaica won their
lottery and i guess a part of their
rules on accepting
the uh jackpot is that you have to come
and physically take and there's like a
little
press release in the newspaper 58
million dollars
it's jamaican money so it's like a 1.5
8.47
here 1.4 million here oh so but this
person
came in a screen mask covered from head
to toe
because they were afraid that their
relatives are going to find out and try
to ask but also probably owes people
money
that's a good point but also the name is
a campbell
so i don't know do you know what i mean
like
but if you're his relative or urban
jamaica like how big do you think
jamaica
is clearly a white guy yeah 90 day
fiance
and not not only that you're like aaron
campbell your last name's
campbell you live in jamaica and you
just buy a new house
and you're not the guy i know but i do
like the
move though because if i'm in the family
even if i know it's him
he's sent his message loud and clear
which is hey do you have family members
try to take advantage of you no are you
close with your family i am but you know
my cousin was famous way before me
who's your cousin scott wolf he was on
party of five okay he's done
been working forever but he was he's
been famous
way before me and not that i'm famous
but in the public eye
but we've never had people from
deep dark recesses of our family pop up
i i see them at shows and you're like
i'm your cousin i'm like cool yeah yeah
but they don't ask you but nobody you
uh no not really if you if you had
something like that
you think somebody would hit you up if
you yes
won the lottery would you
think would you give a certain amount to
your dad your mom
your brother or not my dad cause he's
pretty set but yeah i mean i
now i give i give back to my family
right i cover a lot of things
uh my jacob asked my stress he said if
you
if you won the lottery would you buy me
a car the car
yeah and i said no well you wouldn't and
he said if you had a hundred dollars
would you give me a penny and i said
yeah
and he said you know it's about the same
i said yeah but i'm still not buying you
a [ __ ]
colors i'm still not buying you like you
got to go out and make your own money
to me though i was talking about this my
friend like to me
like with my brother or whoever else
like it's much more fun for me if we're
all
at like doing this together it's not
just me on top of the mountain like
we're all doing it without a doubt but
it's also
how cool is it for you it's cool to me
to call my brother and go think boy made
this much and he owns
ten percent dude think boy did this much
this month and ago what
you know what else is going to be super
cool and this honestly to me has been
my absolute favorite part of any kind of
extra [ __ ] i get things that i can jacob
was the batboy
for the red sox during a weekend series
against the dodgers in dodger stadium
love it
he wore the uniform he was in the dugout
jacob was the bat boy at dodger stadium
for the cardinals i have a picture of
him
high-fiving albert pujols as he crosses
the plate
those kind of things you'll be able to
stay right there
yeah pools bite your [ __ ]
you bite your tongue around baseball too
long
my man he's aging the way here like that
and not be on
trt or something dude have you seen the
way he aged yeah he's aged like a
regular like griffy age yeah sure
you're not buying that [ __ ] at all not
with poo holes how many homers he hit
yeah but look how look at the drop off
it's a not seems like a natural
yeah you might be right drop off his
injuries sure
you're not buying that ah it's tough why
because of his age
i don't know just his performance but if
you lose baseball why wouldn't you take
steroids
i and real quick just so you know i
think everybody's on by the way
i would if you told me hey you can have
a hundred million dollar contract and
take steroids
or you can get a 500 000 minor league
a contract i'd be like okay let's say
where's the needle give me the [ __ ]
for comedy if they say hey if you inject
this into your ass
your set will be a hundred percent
better and you're gonna make
a hundred million instead of ten million
yeah yeah
so i'll tell you how big is the needle
yeah you're saying so it's i'm just
going to be better at what i do
yeah then i'll do that yeah i don't
quite understand
why i think people are so
angry about it because they think they
think it's cheating they don't realize
everybody else is doing this it's
actually 11
level playing field but by the way back
in the day when they weren't taking
steroids
they were taking uppers that's taking
some or cocaine
but no they used to take amphetamines in
the in the dugout
so like they've always done something
i don't know what the problem is just a
competitive uh advantage in the military
it's like the nazis took
uh uh you know [ __ ] basically meth
that took cocaine really oh yeah dude
they couldn't figure out what how
through in the middle of the winter
they're moving
so fast like how the f and they're on
foot and they're in tank and cleaning as
they go okay everybody here we go
make sure that trees clean literally the
american army's like how the [ __ ] are
they moving so fast
they figured out they're taking meth and
cocaine like a [ __ ]
moving like this but what they did
realize like oh there's going to be side
effects from this
so they start off real fast and then
crash like a [ __ ] we took
advantage of it
yeah you know an army of people with no
teeth and
and but those first those are talking
about the plans they have for when they
get home yeah when i get home i'm going
to make the first ever rocket power ship
do those first three days you didn't
want to [ __ ] with them though no which
we did it we're like yeah go ahead dude
i
caught up with him and beat the [ __ ] at
him i did meth once by accident
by accident math by accident no wonder
you have depression it was by
i thought it was coke my buddy was like
do you want to do some coke
josh i didn't know it was meth you
snorted it though yeah it was rough
it was it's the only time i've ever been
kicked out of a strip club
and i got kicked out because look i did
one hit
one line and i'm no quitter so i did
another one just to make sure it was bad
and it was terrible math i had this
crazy
thin layer of sweat like a slime just a
slime
and at the time i was wearing like
button-down shirts tucked into my acid
wash jeans you know with my black belt
you know what i'm saying yeah
and uh i'm out at the um strip club
and i have this thin layer of sweat and
i didn't realize i got home
sweat on my shirt sweat on the underarms
and
this is how bad i looked i couldn't get
a dancer
to give me a lap dance tough i kept
going dance and they were like
pass hard pass so this woman would go
how about can we go into the boom boom
room she was like yeah
she walked me into a door i walked in
she shut the door
it was the way leading outside the back
i couldn't get back in i had to walk
back out into the parking lot
i walked up to the front ticket booth
and i said hey i was supposed to get a
dance
and she must she let me outside by
accident she goes no that was an
accident
she was like your night's over yeah yeah
your night's over we have a giant puerto
rican
i said we have one giant puerto rican
who will dance for you with one realty
just keep getting giant puerto ricans
we have a giant puerto rican with one
tit she says she's familiar with you
she says she knows what you like yeah oh
yeah
you like it rough yeah kicked out of the
strip club but the math was
i hated it i i can't understand any drug
heroin is the only one where i'm like
yeah i probably shouldn't ever do that
i probably love it but that's because
the first half
of every heroin movie looks like the
most fun you'll ever have
the first half before the [ __ ] goes down
you're like oh they're having you watch
the movie blow i want
all the cocaine in the world dude that
looks like a good
[ __ ] time no george jung is basically
trying to convert to a female now i
think
has got a titty implant what but stevie
blue eyes was
was bunk mates with george jung how but
george young's got to be
70 right now right he has a set of tits
you know that's the maybe the one thing
that i uh i'm not
i don't know that i'm looking forward to
these women who have fake boobs being
grandmothers
i don't know how that's gonna be with
all these grandmas with grandma's big
tits yeah
why not yeah i love it you do why not
want a little grandma today yeah
if if i'm a grandpa i'd like my
grandmother when you're
a grandpa yeah that's going to happen
you're a grandpa now four times over man
jesus christ four of those little that's
so cool man
it's so crazy they call me i told you
what i wanted them to call me what
you didn't tell me my son said you can
pick your grandfather name and i said
cool i said call me back tomorrow i'll
have a list of three
gramps and i there was first of all i
told beth i go no nobody's ever called
me grandpa or i'm not i'm not turning
around at the park for someone calling
me grandpa grandpa josh i'm too young
that's cute though
okay i said can i pick any name and he
said yeah
so beth went with bb her first name
starts to be
my great-grandmother's name was bibi so
she and bb's easy for kids to say
so i my son trevor called me back he
goes what do you want the kids to call
you i said beth wants to be called bibi
and i would like to be called lebron
lebron and he was like what i go how
cool
does it sound if you go to bb in the
bronze house like that sounds like
that's cute and at a park if someone
just started screaming with lebron
they're looking for the black dad but
and when i show up they're gonna be
disappointed yeah i thought it'd be
funny and he was like
he even said to me does everything have
to be a joke with you i'm like
that's pretty funny yeah yeah i dig it
yeah what else you guys i'm jojo he
wouldn't let me do baby jojo jojo that's
cool too
this is so dope so the house from fresh
prince of bel air is gonna be
up for on airbnb for rent is
but whatever but yeah you can rent out
the
mansion for a couple nights starting
september 29th it's in bel air and it's
it's 30.
uh close to brentwood so it's not really
built it's not really built
they're not gonna let you run out of
better no and thirty dollars and they're
hurting at thirty dollars a night
for per room right i have no idea if
it's
the entire house or if it's per room but
they have some photos and who
will owns it i don't think he owns it i
think they're doing it to promote
they're doing a reunion of the fresh
prince and they're bringing back their
original on video so it's three
years why can't people leave [ __ ] alone
are you not gonna watch the friends
reunion you don't watch friends
i like friends i like joey joey's so
funny joey lives close to me with the
same car guy and he's
the biggest car guy is he the biggest he
was leblanc
yeah matt leblanc's the biggest car head
you know biggest gearhead
no [ __ ] he was on uh top gear he was a
host for top gear
he was yeah they want to do another
season he's like let me think let me my
residuals i get 26 million every january
i
know 26 million every january
and dude how about how hot is jeffrey
anderson
come on come on start instagram you're
like holy
[ __ ] no she's her her and she's
effortless
but her her her body is
is really remarkable really remarkable i
will tell you that i never
i am more of a fan of her as she's
gotten older
like i love these pictures of her dude
come on
unbelievable a little alarming that
she's never been married with kids
that's usually a red flag for me
something's going on there yeah one time
no one tried to make you she was married
to didn't she
marry justin yeah they were married yeah
who
trudeau justin
yeah that's right but uh justin's the
north star for white guys
he's he's our kanye for fashion he's a
fashion goddess yeah
i i is the best fashion in the game have
you ever seen him he's also
he's so hot brilliant writer great
writer did you know he wrote uh tropic
thunder yeah great rider he's smaller
than you would think he's not a big dude
i i got really his hand look at his
[ __ ] fashion
when they'll be like uh justin aside to
get groceries and like god he looks cool
yeah i wish i was that can wear just
about anything
i i i got lucky
i went to stern's 60th birthday party
and i got a chance to talk to this dude
just for like
an hour he's so [ __ ]
smart yeah yeah and interesting i see
him with the beanie on there
i don't did you wait right
did you ever watch the show knocked over
too many dog pigs did you watch the
leftovers no
on hbo he never let too many dog picks
yeah yeah
oh he's a lady of the [ __ ] the redone
lay in the trap what do you think about
that reader
you're out i don't like you you see lion
king redo nah man i
just leave as a [ __ ] cartoon yeah did
you watch mulan
uh my wife and my mother-in-law and my
kid watched it and said it was the worst
movie they've seen in a long time really
they said it was awful it's also getting
terrible ratings and china hates it
yeah well then which is weird because
they did all the adjustments for china
china hates it why does china hate it
look at justin kill in the game dude
dude this dude
but he that's the one thing boots come
on he can
he spirit animal dude he's my spirit
which one but which one of these outfits
are your
is your thing all of them if i if i
have those boots on the left and in the
second one into the right
i think the only one of those outfits
that i wish i could pull off is the far
right
the the moto jacket yeah i like that
whole vibe i like that whole i like the
the original rocky fedora
i like that whole thing i just want he
knows that he's got pictures taken i
wonder if
he's like all right i gotta grab
groceries i know there's gonna be
paparazzi i'm gonna
sport this i will he's the north star
for as far as like fashion goes he's our
kanye well what makes me happy
is the size of his legs that means
there's still hope for me
you know i mean like that is a chicken
leg
that second picture that is a that one
look at those legs
whoo those are tiny i feel pretty good
about myself now man
that is god
even with a scarf there dude just
popping it but that's the thing by the
way i'm not i love him huh cat he is so
fine
are you on board for scarf i'm not on
buffer scarf uh
i think it depends on the person like
jude he pulls it off and
yeah dude lock and do it uh lenny
kravitz with a huge scarf
it's ridiculous but lenny kravitz can do
whatever you want to do
it's his daughter too oh she's catwoman
yeah
zoe kravitz how old is she though i
think like uh
she's like she's married yeah uh
late twenties early thirties okay lenny
kravitz has no results
quite a run
i didn't 31 yeah did you see the photo
of him with his ripped jeans on stage
oh and his lenny kravitz a couple years
ago yeah and then people found out his
dick was pierced
yeah oh you didn't see that his pants
ripped on stage
and hug there was a little bit of a
piercing on the penis 56 it's albert
56 this dude is still i mean
could get it with anybody it's so crazy
yeah there it is oh they're just covered
up though oh weak there we are but it's
not
by the way that yeah that person the
front row was like oh
well hello that
what would you do if that happened to
you on stage i've had my pants rip on
stage
dig out i had underwear on why does he
have no underwear with leather pants
a lot of people ask that question it's
not there you go he's a rock star
oh it's all right he's it's all right
but also when you're on stage your
dick's like all right let's retreat
yeah you're not this is you're not very
sweaty and hot i'm sharing those
but you would wear underwear with
leather pants i'd wear underwear with
everything it's not comfortable i i'm
with you with jeans and stuff but i
don't think i wear
underwear with leather pants what about
lenny crab is that your style
he yes absolutely he's so fine
so you like a thinner dude like no
problem with thin nudes i have no
problem with
chubby dudes who's a chubby guy you find
attractive uh
i remember when straight out of compton
came out i was in love with o'shea
jackson jr
i just thought he was so cute oh that's
uh ice cube excuse me yeah he was just
like short and short fat
i like short chubby dudes
she likes bo documentary you like the
dick where you gonna lift up the stomach
a little bit just to make sure it can
get all the way in there
that's your all right cat okay i have a
very
vast yeah that is a why between that and
justin thoreau
that's a huge that's a huge difference
yeah congratulations
what else you guys got um
oh yours bren this made me laugh so hard
have you ever been doing a showing down
an argument with someone
yeah you mean with like eric griffin the
other day yeah
kind of you guys weren't that heated no
not heated i guess a little bit yeah
right i mean
we got into it yeah watch this this is
great i think you have a clue of where
you're gonna trade them
who might be in the market where you
might be able to get something not just
hey let me throw this against the wall
see what stakes okay i mean you make fun
of other people for doing that
really
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not doing the show no i you're the
one telling me to leave if you want me
to leave i'll leave but just quit crying
you can talk about this during the break
do the show
do it i'm just gonna do the show about
myself then yeah why are you here
deuce do the show just quit crying about
it keep
talk talk sports and quit crying for two
straight segments
was that supposed to be funny because
yes that's hilarious
shut up crying and keeping this going on
and just do the show
oh good god you're a child man quit
being petty and do the show the radio
the show sounds horrible you can tell
you guys calling a [ __ ]
no i started doing the research you
asked me to do the last check out
no you
i'm not going to sit here it's already
been two segments of horrible if you
want me to leave i'll cut off the mic
and i'll leave just do the show it
sounds horrible i'll do the show
thank you so much okay
[Music]
do the show quit being a [ __ ] whatever
i'm the one doing the show you're the
one checking out have a good day see you
go on dudes do the show [ __ ]
wait a second that's the most
embarrassing
are they in the same room oh yeah why do
they have different backdrops
first of all oh they are in the same
room
the producer's like well that's enough
yeah what were they arguing about do you
know
they're mad because houston right
they're lost and then they're talking
about
the rockets trading james harden and
they just got [ __ ]
heated but that brian i've had some seat
like
when we had joe coy on there brian was
mad cause we're talking about aliens and
we believed him like with that
uh he called you bob bob blazer brian
was like you guys are [ __ ] infants
like dead serious like we've had me and
brian have had it out on the show a
number of times about aliens
aliens one time with joe coy you even
joe was laughing but
he was heated we were literally shouting
i mean brian i've gotten into it like a
[ __ ]
i um i don't mean i don't believe
editing that stuff it's like no
i mean bro that's good that's probably
more interesting than any [ __ ] radio
they've ever done
brian's like your brother so we argue
like brothers but so he gets heated dude
that's good dude
but i'm just gonna i'm on team bryan
with the aliens
yeah you don't believe into it i think
there are aliens seem to think
i think they're aliens i just thought
these are full of [ __ ] i don't
think they haven't been here i think
they're i don't think we're the only
people in the universe
i just think it is so crazy to think
that we have all of these cameras and
detection satellite so you don't think
the government's ever seen aliens
even though and this was during the
middle of the pandemic
the white house confirmed that they have
ufos they have them
in their possession that are from an
unknown world they confirm they have
ufos
i think well they say that vaguely but
they confirm
they have technology they they can't
confirm
they said they found parts from a crash
yes but
it's not they said it was also like a an
arbitrary
like consultant so it wasn't really the
pentagon or anything so it was a
consultant that said that i've never
seen this from this world
i think honestly that it's just
technology that we don't have yet
china russia more likely that i think
it's china russia more likely we're seen
more likely yeah technology that we have
never seen so far
but by the way i think
that there are things out there i think
there's probably
an earth somewhere out there that
mirrors this
pretty closely 100 i just
i just have a hard time believing that
a they came here but only in the 50s
when we didn't have the technology to
really keep track of them coming well
they've been here since but you see that
what about the military
video where you military pilots and
it's in the ocean the way they move and
the speed they move and the temperature
they're like
we don't know we literally can't tell
you yeah i can't keep up with it
when it flies too low the temperature
would be at negative
30 like anything that fast we can't see
the motor we can't see the with the
propulsion
and it's it's like small enough to where
a human being couldn't fit
in it so i think drones to be honest
yeah and my
my only just crazy drone technology yeah
my only thing is this
is like why would they be so scared of
us
are they if they're so much more
advanced than us no they're coming just
like how these people are [ __ ]
but like no it just it's hard for me to
to really take in that there's been no
contact there's been no
definitive sighting hold on no contact
that the government's gonna tell you
about
okay so no contact i mean why but why
hasn't nobody else in the entire world
with
like i said with all the technology we
have now
nobody like china and russia tell us no
the [ __ ] just
regular citizens with buying with
telescopes that can see wherever the
[ __ ] i just mean there's so many
so many people have said they've seen
stuff though said they've seen stuff so
many people have said they've seen
bigfoot too i mean look until
until i s until i see one okay
why why are they anal probing like why
is that the one move that everybody's
gonna be talking about i i think they
have been here
i do i i've told you i believe i i don't
think that bob laser is complete full of
[ __ ]
when you hear a story like after all
these years you think he'd have some
hiccup in his lies like there's
the detail he talks about working on the
on the
on ufos that they have at area 51 for
the government
yeah trying to figure out the the elect
the the technology behind it
dude can i tell you i hope there are
like these aren't things like i hope
there are i would love
i think that's incr fascinating
obviously that's [ __ ] understating it
i hope there are aliens i hope they come
down and go
hey you know we can do this you want to
do this i hope they're cool then we all
get along because you just i just don't
think it has happened i for me i don't
think it's
this i saw this on yahoo a little while
ago so i guess
a russian astronaut that's staying on
the international space station
wanted to capture that aurora borealis
so yeah this like uh
yeah you know the time lapse video yeah
and he captured some things around like
the nine-second marketing so i'll show
you i don't know this is the whole
long one so i'm not sure if this the one
i saw capture that nine seconds in
on the original the yahoo video but
let's see
that is so [ __ ] cool though
wait do you think that's an alien no no
so that's the aurora borealis
let me find the original video you guys
can let me ask you something you you
watched the
show away have you seen it basically
there's a mission to mars it's going to
take three years okay
if you had the opportunity to go into
space but i'm
would you not do it no the three years
away from everybody i but that
seems like would you do that would you
go away [ __ ] am i gonna do when i get up
there
like would you would you do that i mean
what is up there i don't think i'm
curious enough
about space to dedicate three years of
my life to it bummer when we get up
there
i i guess to say that you were in space
and landed on mars like
no and but you're probably i don't know
how many people have landed on mars it
can't be very many if
if any people none right so
this show is about landing and and but
you wouldn't be
to go to them i don't know how long does
it take to get to the moon no idea
what would you no desire you're no
desire no desire to go to me
how's it going for buzz i mean but but
he can say he was killing it
no but what a crazy experience you don't
care at all not at all you're not
curious at all to know three day
you wouldn't take three days out of your
life to get in a [ __ ]
rocket ship instead of going to
hilarities in cleveland nope
i'm gonna say hello i'm gonna send you
to the [ __ ] moon no what am i gonna
do dude you're gonna be on the moon bruh
yeah
i'm gonna tell you how was the moon ah
dude
but you i was out there we were like oh
that's cool but you got three pros
the earth from the moon you get to be in
space that is mind-boggling
neither one of you any too risky for me
me too too risky
oh [ __ ] goes bad too i don't like flying
oh dude i think every time it flies a
risk and i hate it yeah i [ __ ] hate
flying too
let alone to the moon
three days you want to take a three-day
plane ride
no but i'll take a straight up [ __ ] on a
rocket ship
yeah dude you want to do that get all
the gear float around for a little while
that would be so dope how cool would it
be to be high
with no gravity zero design i'm not sure
if they'd let me take any edibles on the
tree
i don't deserve really zero i don't know
if they went up they're like hey
we've been up there for 10 years they
built a city it's better than vegas
there's tons of cool people up there
restaurants
you go to the moon to get a meal bro i
need something more than just
walking around and then telling people
no people like yeah dude yeah we saw
buzz aldrin
won't shut up about it he like does
seminars now talking about it
i i i would
i would maybe mars seems too long on the
moon and then
let's say you went to the moon tonight
yeah came back on the show on monday you
wouldn't have any questions for me
how was it dude you go oh it's cool man
i like
walked around like that's cool anyways
what else you got chance
what are we gonna talk about i don't
know i haven't been to the moon yet it's
like you tell me a girl you hooked up
with
i don't give a [ __ ] dude i wasn't there
i can i can bring up pictures on [ __ ]
google
but but but but you would you would swim
go underwater swim with sharks and do
all that stuff
yeah but i wouldn't come back and like
talk your ear off about it because you
weren't there
yeah but what a crazy experience to
share with people
have you heard buzz aldrin talking like
oh my god 190 years old
you didn't when he was young you watch
the interviews like all right cool dude
i no i for me things like that that
very few people i'd rather watch gravity
with george clooney
oh my god i have no desire no one's
gonna give a flying
[ __ ] dude jeez are you
kidding no one would care okay so buzz
aldrin
you just said is still giving talks
because that's all he had
170 years after he did it people are
still curious
no they're not nobody gets to do it so i
bet
he opens up any questions what was it
like on the moon
you know pretty dark uh it's cold up
there i'm out
i'm out i don't give a [ __ ]
you would you yeah man what question
would you ask buzz aldrin that he has
answered a hundred million times that i
couldn't get from george clooney in
gravity
i don't what do you what would you ask
him what did you ask him well here's his
name what was it like
the things that i would ask him he
couldn't give me a satisfactory answer
to because i would have to experience it
correct
so i would love to be in a i want to
know what it's like that kind of g-force
taking off
i want to know what it's like just
basically floating through space i want
to know what it looks like up there
i want to i want to see i just want to
only one way to find out josh do it do
it
and then keep it to yourself
because we cuz we don't kill
like if someone said hey buzz aldrin
once come on the podcast i'm like
all right i guess you know it's like
we weren't there keep it to yourself
dude
what else you got jen want some more uh
is that it
um we have let's get let's end on all
right
i mean if you go dude i guess shoot me
attack i won't i'm not even going to let
you know man you know what
send me a selfie i guess i might be you
know if you took a selfie
on the moon the moon with the earth
behind me like this i'm like oh damn
that's crazy have fun man that's it
not yet you're not even asking and
you're like whatever i mean i guess it'd
be a good pr move you're like okay i'll
be hilarity's next weekend yeah you're
gonna be you can sell service up there
yeah dude how's the merch
[Applause]
what are we gonna do with that dude do
you see any animals
no there's nothing up there dude i can't
even believe there's
nothing up no it's the moon how was it
dude it was pretty
just what you expect when off the movies
uh pretty cold
darkest [ __ ] nothing else was out here
oh my god
well you i definitely not gonna tell you
next time i go
that's it i'm not done when i go to the
moon dude guess who's not hearing about
it
you [ __ ] you're gonna miss out
am i
everybody else is gonna hear the moon
stories dude not you
it's around the comments you're here
joshua move damn that's crazy yeah dude
what do you do he told me not to tell
you he just kind of like walked around
it was like dark and that's it man and
then he came back three days later
everyone's like
that's a fun story i guess yeah good for
josh
meanwhile i mean i it's so funny that
you're like i would definitely take
hilarities
100 over the moonwalk 100 i will tell
you this though
if you told me i could learn how to
moonwalk like michael jackson i would
take that moonwalk
over the actual moon we can do that can
you moonwalk like michael jackson no
but i guarantee i could find someone to
teach me do you know what that's more
impressive than you going to the moon
just
oh my god i think buzz has any talent
no dude they put him in the suit because
there's good eyesight
do you think that's easy to be an
astronaut
if that's what you want to do and you're
the and you have a high level iq and you
can see straight
you know if you have good vision it's
not impressive
are you impressed by astronauts yeah man
i think the training to be an astronaut
is kind of
pretty extensive yeah i'm more impressed
with navy seals
they're all so impressive i can be
impressed with two different people
yeah but i'm not like are you are you
buying uh like uh
an astronaut t-shirt like i don't know
i'm probably not
buying i'm more impressed with like
fighter pilots then the guys go on the
moon
yeah fighter pilots too also i'm more
impressed with the guy who built the
spaceship
me too not the guy who sat there like
this
i i think they're all you know they're
not even driving it
you know they're it's controlled from
down below
doing something dude it's not a remote
control car that is
no it's not they gotta flick buttons and
[ __ ] no they do this you don't think
they do three
two one and they do that the whole and
for the whole time they're just floating
around and then they
get out they take a leisurely stroll and
get the [ __ ] back in this oh my god
are you i'm not impressed with
astronauts apparently not they got balls
i respect what they do but
all right but they're put there it's
just right
what's more impressed with the guy that
got rid of what's more impressive say
the
nascar driver astronaut
nascar driver okay all right
uh dude who takes his uh go-kart to 35
miles an hour
on saturdays in vegas at the track or
astronaut astronaut
okay because anybody could do that on a
go-kart not everybody could be an
astronaut like you'd be an astronaut
you'd be pretty [ __ ] smart
but there's a ton of smart people josh
but there aren't he just decided there
aren't a ton of astronauts
we're not that easy to be an astronaut
you wouldn't know i'm gonna by the way
i don't know the requirements yeah but
it's
it's pretty dicey but i was about
i'm not smart enough but those people
that are that smart that decide to do it
it doesn't i'm not like
like oh my god how'd you do it no dude
you're smart
we've to we put monkeys in suits dude i
hope there's another
monkey who listens to your show and they
can tell us this guy
can tell us what the requirements are i
bet you
super difficult again i agree super
difficult to get into nasa you have to
be a smart [ __ ] yeah
i'm just not impressed with the guys
that decide to jump in the suits and go
to space
all right all right okay the ones who
like with the engineering of the rockets
and [ __ ] those who
i want to talk to what's more impressive
an actual moonwalk or this dude and his
moonwalk let me see
this is the best moonwalk ever
oh wow that is pretty good [ __ ] yeah
that's good because that's on cement
that's sideways
and then eventually it goes to the back
on cement isn't easy
why'd they put that video up there oh
that's fantastic yeah
that answer i'm telling you on cement
with the cracks that is
outstanding and just doing it without
creasing his shoes yeah
that's the most impressive part without
creasing the shoes yeah yeah
pretty impressive that's impressive all
right i'm more impressed with that
just kidding this guy nasa's gonna be
simple
i know i know the rocket scientists i
don't are the
but are the people that touch down like
was buzzing
was buzz was his iq crazy was he a
rocket scientist
i don't know how hard is it to be an
astronaut
takes many years again
that's a very that doesn't space.com
yeah space.com tells you it's a very
hard job to get
thank you odds 18 300 people applied
2017.
point zero four percent or eight percent
i realize they're smart as [ __ ]
yeah i'm a aware of that but i'm just
not impressed yeah with them doing it
all right well i mean i'm i'm
bachelor's degree engineering by that's
a lot of smart thousand dollars a pilot
in command so they need a bachelor's
degree in engineering biological science
physical science computer science or
math oh one of those followed by three
years professional experience
thousand hours of pilot in command time
in the jet craft
cats also must pass the nasa's astronaut
physical
huh i mean
when it's just written out like that it
doesn't seem like
anything like more intensive than
getting your
you're becoming a doctor also not
money's not everything but
you know on the high end they're making
144 grand
but you're an astronaut you go to space
oh yeah how long
you're going once your entire career is
dedicated to space and you go once every
[ __ ]
how about we're not up there that much
no we have satellites
if they are up there it's a countdown on
every local news station so yeah and i'm
saying you're never
going to be on that countdown i'm not
even going to
you know the [ __ ] idiots that go out
and crap i'm not doing that
with billboards three two one
and then the [ __ ] jeff yeah i'm not
doing that i'm not doing that i'm not
doing that
you're a citizen all right possess a
masculine stem field see again
they're way smarter and smarter you're
monsters have at least two years really
okay
yeah i get a complete a doctor of
medicine or doctor oh wow
wow another beast all right so there's a
lot of smarts that goes into this
i assume for nasa yeah they only send in
our smartest of space i think i'm just
not impressed
if you combined our iqs i don't think
we're
we're not we're not going no i don't
think we're making it either we're not
making it no you know what
i don't want to make it no apparently
not you don't i support what they do but
i don't care
yeah this is i'm going to tell you if
you're building a hotel
on mars what if check it out what if
they played longwood is it called
longwood what's longwood oh yellowstone
yellowstone sorry
it was only if i called it what if
what if i played yellowstone the whole
way up or if i could only watch
yellowstone but i have to get to the
moon yeah i'm getting to the moon
that's the only thing that's getting me
to the moon all right all right dude i'm
gonna be in the columbus
october second and third check it out
also guys if you
if you haven't seen my special it's free
on my youtube channel
uh check that out last night we had uh
freddie prinze
jr uh eric griffin and zainab johnson on
control chaos we had like
another i think a hundred and eighty
thousand on griffin
great love freddie great so and check
out the shows
monday night on my facebook fan page at
seven tuesday night on my facebook fan
page at seven
those are when the live shows are check
them out go see josh ruff and then uh
my tickets for dallas just went on sale
i'm at the addison improv
in dallas texas you [ __ ] moon loving
[ __ ] i'm in uh
october october first october
october first i don't know i'm so
grateful for 19. october
1st through the 3rd i'm in dallas texas
get your tickets my whole squad will be
with me
i'm in nashville november 19th through
the 21st get your tickets now t5k.com
they're limited tickets so they will go
fast get them now
dallas nashville europe baby have you
been to
the gas monkey garage in dallas what is
it
i know i'm gonna who am i shooting with
colin colin noir and peter or boy peter
the gas monkey garage i think what was
the name of the
show fast and furious
my garage richard rawlings is the is the
guy who
if you see him you're fast and loud fast
and loud oh wow have you been to their
garage
no do you want me to set that up it is
super dope my brother would love that
is he into that stuff in the cars yeah
yeah we both
dude gas monkey this dude his show has
been on for
i don't know super popular um but
their garage is so [ __ ] cool oh yeah
i'd love that
he he he had bought farrah fawcett's
cor her original corvette that they
redid for her
it was one of the first uh cars that had
a phone in it it had a dial phone that's
cool
in the [ __ ] car it's cool but when he
got it he's got a bunch of cool [ __ ]
like that
yeah i'll set that up for you let's do
it get your tickets dallas october 1st
through the 3rd dfatk.com
josh i love you man yeah thanks man
thanks for having me appreciate it it's
fun
later we're out